ALL RIGHT WE LIKE TO
CALL THE ASSEMBLY SELECT
COMMITTEE ON NATIVE AMERICAN
AFFAIRS- TO ORDER THIS IS THE
OVERSIGHT HEARING- TODAY
DEALING WITH NATIVE AMERICAN
GRAVES PROTECTION AND
REPATRIATION ACT SPECIFICALLY-
A FOLLOW UP- ON IN PROGRESS ON
A REPORT THAT CAME OUT OF- J.
LACK IN HERE WITH ME AS A
CHAIRMAN OF THE ASSEMBLY- J.
LACK A RUDY SALAS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS. IT WILL BE-
HEARING TESTIMONY OF OVERSEEING
THE RETURNS OF NATIVE AMERICAN
REMAINS AND ARTIFACTS. AS
RELATED TO REPORT NUMBER TWO
ZERO NINETEEN DASH ZERO FOUR
SEVEN. I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY HERE AND WELCOME YOU
TO THIS NATIVE AMERICAN SELECT
COMMITTEE AFFAIRS. AND THAT
THIS TIME WE'D LIKE TO GIVE
LAND RECOGNITION TO THE TRIBES
FROM THE AREA- THE MEANWHILE
THIS IN ON IN PART WHEN PEOPLE
FROM THE SACRAMENTO AREA. WHEN
HE LANDED KNOWLEDGE INTO THEM I
THINK IT THEM FOR. ALL OTHER
IMPORTANT TO THIS AREA BEFORE
WE GO TO GET STARTED THIS TOPIC
NEED TO PROVIDE SOME
INFORMATION- MASS. ARE
REQUIRING A REQUIREMENTS TO BE
WORN IN THE HEARING ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL BUILDING
IF YOU DO NOT HAVE A MASS WE
CAN PROVIDE. YOU ONE NOW ALSO
REMOTE TESTIMONY IT IS LIVE FOR
THIS. HEARING IN ADDITION TO
BEING MADE TO PROVIDE COMMENTS
FROM INSIDE THE HEARING ROOM
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC CAN MAKE
USE OF OUR REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. LOCATED ON THE NORTH
STEPS OF THE CAPITOL DIAL IN
INFORMATION WE WILL USE A
PUBLIC MODERATE A TELEPHONE
SERVICE FOR WITNESSES AND FOR
THE PUBLIC. THE CALLING NUMBER
FOR THIS HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS TWENTY FOUR. DASH TWENTY SIX
DASH TWO THREE SEVEN. YOU CAN%
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY'S WEBSITE IN ON YOUR
TV SCREEN. THE NUMBER AGAIN FOR
THE CALL IN INFORMATION FOR
TESTIMONY PUBLIC COMMENT IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. IN
THE ACCESS CODE IS TWENTY FOUR
DASH TWENTY SIX TWO THREE
SEVEN. THE OPERATOR ON THE LINE
WILL GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW TO BE PLACED IN THE QUEUE
TO PROVIDE YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT.
IF YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISES. THIS INCLUDES MUTING
YOUR LIVESTREAM BROADCAST IN
YOUR SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE
THE SOUND DISTORTION. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION NOW
MOVING ON TO THE TOPIC OF
TODAY'S HEARING TODAY WILL BE
DISCUSSING THE FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS IDENTIFIED BY
THE STATE AUDITOR IN THE AUDIT
REPORT RELEASED IN JUNE OF TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY. TITLE NATIVE
AMERICAN GRAVES PROTECTION AND
REPATRIATION AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA IS A NOT
ADEQUATELY OVERSEEN ITS RETURNS
OF NATIVE AMERICAN REMAINS AND
ARTIFACTS. ON THESE LANDS
NATIVE AMERICANS ESTABLISHED-
BURIAL SITES AND CULTURAL
RESOURCES AS TIME PASSED THE
SITES HAVE BEEN UNDER
CONSTRUCTION DELIVERS SEARCHES
OR OTHER CHANGES IN THE LANDING
IN ADVERT AND DISCOVERY OF
NATIVE AMERICAN REMAINS.
BEGINNING IN NINETEEN NINETY
SPECIFIED INSTITUTIONS WITH
THESE REMAINS AND ARTIFACTS
WERE REQUIRED TO CREATE
INVENTORIES THROUGH
CONSULTATION WITH TRIBES AND
SUBSEQUENTLY TRIBES COULD
SUBMIT CLAIMS TO ANY ITEMS
AFFILIATED WITH THEM.
THROUGHOUT THE YEARS
REPATRIATION HAS BECOME A
LENGTHY AND CONFUSING PROCESS
NOT ONLY FOR THE TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES BUT ALSO FOR. THOSE
THAT HAVE ON THE REMAINS IN
THEIR ARCHIVES DESPITE VARIOUS
EFFORTS TO RETURN ITEMS TO
DRIVE RECLAMATION SUCCESS. HAS
BEEN MINIMAL AND THERE HAS BEEN
SOME SUCCESS STORIES BUT IT HAS
BEEN MINIMAL OVERALL AND AS
THE- FIRST CALIFORNIA INDIAN
ELECTED THE STATE LEGISLATURE
WE FIND THAT IT'S OUR
STEWARDSHIP TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE CONTINUE TO PRESS THE- THE
ENVELOPE TO MAKE SURE THESE
REMAINS COME BACK TO THE
RIGHTFUL OWNERS. AND THE
REMAINS HAVE BEEN TAKEN FROM
THE GROUND MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE GIVING BACK TO THE
REPATRIATION PROCESS FOR A
PROPER REBURIAL WE CONTINUE TO
WORK TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE THAT
PROCESS DOES MOVE FORWARD.
THAT'S WHAT THIS HEARING IS
ABOUT IS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
GET AN UPDATE FROM THE LAST
HEARING THAT WE HAD. TO FIND
OUT WHERE THE PROGRESS IS IN
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE WORKING
TOGETHER. TO GET THESE REMAINS
BACK INTO THE RIGHTFUL OWNERS
THE TRIBAL PEOPLE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. FOR A PROPER
BURIAL. LAST JUNE THE AUDITOR
RELEASED A TROUBLE REPORT.
ABOUT THE VAST NUMBER REMAINS
HELD BY THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SYSTEM. IT WAS
DURING THAT SAMPLE AUDIT REPORT
THAT. CAME TO LIGHT THAT THE UC
SYSTEM STILL- HELD OVER FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND NATIVE
AMERICAN REMAINS. THIS IS THE
ISSUE THAT WE CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THIS ISSUE THEY WERE GOING
TO GET AN UPDATE FROM SEVERAL
SPEAKERS HERE TODAY PENNY
RECOMMENDATIONS RANGE FROM THE
AUDIT COMMITTEE. ENSURING THAT
TRIBAL REPRESENTATION IS
INCLUDED. ON APPROPRIATE CAMPUS
COMMITTEES. CONSISTENCY AND
TIME LINES IN THE REVIEW OF
TRAVEL CLAIMS. AND PROVIDING
GREATER TRANSPARENCY ABOUT
KNOWN MISSING REMAINS AN
APPROPRIATE COMMUNICATION.
AUDITOR HOW WILL PROVIDE MORE
INFORMATION SHORTLY ABOUT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE STATUS
OF IMPLEMENTATION. ALSO WITH US
IS UC PROVOST. MICHAEL BROWN
AND UC BERKELEY VICE CHANCELLOR
FOR RESEARCH WILL PRESENT THE
UC SYSTEM'S RESPONSE. ALSO WITH
US IS TRIBAL CHAIRMAN LEO
CISCO. OF THE TOUCHY OKAY
TRIBE. WHO WILL PRESENT THE
TRIBAL PERSPECTIVE. ALSO WE HAD
SCHEDULED WITH US BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THE CHAIR ONE
BECAME ILL. CHARLENE NAPA OF
THE MILL OUT. ALONI TRIBE. WAS
ALSO SCHEDULED AS A PRESENTER.
BUT HAS WE HAVE BEEN INFORMED
ISSUES IT ALSO TAKING HER PLACE
WILL BE- CHAIRWOMAN LOUISE J.
MARANDA ROMERO'S OF THE ALONI
COSTA KNOW AND- S. ONE NATION.
WHO WILL FOLLOW CHAIRMAN CISCO
YOU WILL HEAR FROM DIFFERENT
PANELISTS YOU'LL HEAR FROM THE
DIFFERENT SPEAKERS ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS TOPIC. AT
THIS TIME I WOULD LIKE TO OFFER
ANY COMMENTS THAT GERMAN SALAS
WOULD HAVE. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALMOST SENT THANK YOU
FOR HAVING THIS HEARING TODAY
AND INVITING MEMBERS OF THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE TO PARTICIPATE- YOU
KNOW THANK YOU FOR ALWAYS BEING
A LEADING VOICE IN A FORCE ON
THIS ISSUE WITH BOTH THE
PORTENT. AND AND VERY PERSONAL
PERSONAL FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- YOU KNOW THIS IS
OUR SECOND HEARING ON THIS
TOPIC- AND SUBSEQUENTLY HERE WE
BROUGHT UP THESE ISSUES BEFORE
WE'VE EXPRESSED INTEREST AND
CONTINUE TO HOLD. HEARINGS
UNTIL THE REMAINS OF ANY
CALIFORNIA'S ANCESTORS OF THEIR
BELONGINGS ARE APPROPRIATELY
RETURNED. I CANNOT THINK OF
ANYTHING MORE PERSONAL.
PERSONAL OR MEANINGFUL TO AN
INDIVIDUAL OUR COMMUNITY THEN
ENSURING THAT ONE'S ANCESTRAL
REMAINS. AND BELONGINGS WERE
GIVEN THE RESPECT AND DIGNITY
THAT THEY RESERVE THAT THEY
DESERVE. LOOKING AT THE ONE
YEAR STATUS OF THE FIVE AUDIT
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. YOU HAVE TO
SAY I AM SADDENED THAT ONLY ONE
HAS BEEN FULLY AND- I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CITY'S.
EXPLOITATION WHY ONLY ONE OUT
OF THE FIVE RECOMMENDATIONS HAS
BEEN FULLY. IMPLEMENTED AB
CAUTIOUSLY HOPEFUL THAT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WILL
BE ABLE TO REASSURE IS TODAY
THAT THEY ARE ON THE CORRECT
PATH AND THAT ALL FIVE
RECOMMENDED. BE IMPLEMENTED.
WITH THANK YOU AGAIN FOR HAVING
THIS HEARING AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO TODAY'S TESTIMONY THANK YOU
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN SALAS- ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE THOSE IN
ATTENDANCE. HAVE ANY ANY
COMMENTS THANK YOU SO NOW WE
WOULD LIKE TO- CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD. WITH THE HEARING AND
OUR FIRST TIME- SPEAKER WILL BE
THE STATE AUDITOR ELAINE HOWELL
AND JIM ADAMS ON THE AUDIT
SUPERVISOR TO PRESENT AN
OVERVIEW OF THE ITEM WHICH WAS
RELEASED LAST YEAR DO WE HAVE
THEM ON ZOOM DO WE HAVE THEM
READY TO GO. GERMANIST AROUND
THE HOUSE AND MEMBERS- CONNECTS
ALL OF I'M NOT SURE YOU CAN
SENIOR VIDEO GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR INVITING US TO SHARE THE
RESULTS OF THE AUDIT THAT WE
ISSUED LAST YEAR IN JUNE OF
TWENTY TWENTY- IS CERTAINLY-
THE UPDATE HIS STATUS AS OF THE
ONE YEAR RESPONSE WE RECEIVED
FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA- AS YOU CAN SEE I
HAVE TWO GENTLEMEN ME MISTER
JOHN ADAMS WAS THE SUPERVISOR
ON THE PROJECT AND DAVID KING
WAS THE ATTORNEY ASSIGNED TO
THE PROJECT THIS THE TEAM IN
CONDUCTING AUDITS SO WHAT I'D
LIKE TO DO BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY IS GO THROUGH THE KEY
ISSUE. WE HAVE FOUR KEY ISSUES-
IN THE REPORT. AND THEN SIX
RECOMMENDATIONS AND ASKED AS
CHAIRMAN SALAS INDICATED. FIVE
OF THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS WERE
DIRECTED AT YOU SEE AND ONE.
RECOMMENDATION WAS DIRECTED THE
LEGISLATURE AND I'LL TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT ONE AS
WELL. AND THEN WHAT I CAN TELL
YOU IF YOU AND I STATUS AS OF
THE ONE YEAR RESPONSE SO AS I'M
SURE YOU'RE AWARE. ANYTIME THE
STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE ISSUED A
REPORT. THE ENTITY THAT WE ARE
AUDITING- PROVIDES RESPONSES AT
SIXTY DAYS SIX MONTHS AND ONE
YEAR ASKS YOU. HOW HOW MUCH
PROGRESS THEY'VE MADE IN
IMPLEMENTING RECOMMENDATIONS SO
I'LL BE SPEAKING ABOUT EACH OF
THOSE- AS I GO THROUGH THE
TESTIMONY TODAY. SO LET'S START
WITH THE FIRST ISSUE AND ADDS.
SHARES RAMOS INDICATED- ONE OF
THE KEY PROBLEMS WE IDENTIFIED
IN THE AUDIT WE LOOKED AT THREE
CAMPUSES WE LOOKED AT. BERKELEY
DAVIS AND YOU UCLA LOS ANGELES
AND- IDENTIFY WILL DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT THEY WERE DOING
A GOOD JOB OF WORKING WITH
TRIBES. I TO MAKE SURE THAT
REMAINS FOR. YOU KNOW THEY WERE
FOLLOWING THE REPATRIATION ACT-
BUT WHAT WE FOUND IS REAL
INCONSISTENCY BETWEEN THE
CAMPUSES- UC BERKELEY HAD. THE
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF ARTIFACTS
AND REMAINS- ON YOUR CAMPUS AND
THEY HAD NOT. DONE A GOOD KALAU
AND WITH THE TRI TO MAKE SURE
THOSE REMAIN WERE RETURNED TO
THEIR TO THEIR RIGHT SO WE
REALLY HAD TO SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS WITH RESPECT TO. THE
AMOUNT OF EVIDENCE THAT THE
CAMPUS IS PARTICULARLY BERKELEY
WAS REQUIRING OF TRIBES TO.
CONFIRM THAT THAT TRIED WAS
AFFILIATED WITH THOSE ARTIFACTS
IN THOSE REMAINS AND THEN
SIMILARLY AS FAR AS
COMMUNICATION THERE NEEDS TO BE
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN THE
CAMPUSES AND TRIBES. WITH
RESPECT THE DISPOSITION OF
SIMILAR PROCESS AGAIN BERKELEY
WAS MUCH MORE STRINGENT AND
THEIR EXPECTATIONS OF TRIBES
RATHER THAN HAVING INFORMAL
COMMUNICATIONS. THEY WERE
EXPECTING THINGS IN WRITING
WHICH REALLY. DELAYED THE
PROCESS THE ABILITY FOR. THOSE
REMAINS AND ARTIFACTS TO BE
RETURNED TO. THE RIGHTFUL OWNER
OF THE APPROPRIATE TRY SO WE
HAD SOME RECOMMENDATIONS TO BE
OFF THE PRESIDENT BECAUSE WHEN
WE LOOK TO THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT TO SEE WHAT KIND OF
GUIDANCE IS THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT PROVIDING TWO
CAMPUSES IN CALIFORNIA THE UC
SYSTEM. OTHERWISE MINIMAL
GUIDANCE SO THAT WAS ONE OF OUR
FIRST RECOMMENDATIONS IS.
REQUIRED. THESE CAMPUSES TO.
PROVIDE ME TWICE A BY TO THE
SYSTEM WHITE CAN SO THAT THAT'S
SYSTEM COMMITTEE COULD REVIEW
WHAT IS PERFECTLY COMPARED TO
UCLA COMPARED TO DAVIS ARE WE
BEING CONSISTENT AS A SYSTEM.
AND OUR INTERACTIONS WITH
TRIBES AND OUR EXPECTATIONS OF
TRIBES AND WE WERE TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT. WE RETURN THOSE
REMAINS IN THOSE ARTIFACTS TO
THE APPROPRIATE TRIED. SO THE
UNIVERSITY THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT HAS RECEIVED REPORTS
FROM- VARIOUS CAMPUSES OUR
CONCERN IS AND I'LL BE TOUCHING
ON THIS IN A COUPLE OF OTHER
THE RECOMMENDATIONS IS A SYSTEM
WIDE COMMITTEE. IS NOT.
REPRESENTATIVE OF WHAT IT
SHOULD SO WE REPORTS HAVE SENT
TO THE- NURSE CALIFORNIA THE
OFFICE OF PRESIDENT WHAT WE
DON'T NO ONE WILL DO FOR THE
FIRST MISTER BROWN IS WHO IS
REVIEWING THOSE REPORTS IS
THERE ANYTHING BE BE DONE WITH
THOSE REPORTS. SO THAT YOU COPY
YES THE PRESIDENT CAN'T BE
WORKING WITH THE CAMPUS IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS PROCESS IS
IMPROVED SO THAT MANY AT THE
REMAINS PARTICULARLY AT
BERKELEY I RETURN TO THE
APPROPRIATE TRIED ONE OF THE
ONE OF THE ISSUES RELATED TO
THAT IS. THE NATIVE AMERICAN
HERITAGE COMMISSION HAS TO
RECOMMEND NOMINEES INDIVIDUALS
WHO SHOULD BE SERVING ON BOTH
CAMPUS COMMUNITIES AND SYSTEM
WIDE COMMITTEES. AND IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING OVER THE COURSE
OF THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS.
IT'S BEEN DIFFICULT FOR IN H.
T. TO COME UP WITH QUALIFIED
INDIVIDUALS- BUT I DO
UNDERSTAND FROM JIM JUST FOUND
SOME RECENT INFORMATION THAT.
AS RECENTLY AS JUNE A COUPLE
MONTHS AGO THAT. SHE WAS ABLE
TO HOLD A SPECIAL MEETING TO
CONSIDER NOMINATION SO- I AGAIN
I'M GONNA DEFERRED AT THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTATIVES. AS TO THE
STATUS SUBSEQUENT TO THAT JUNE
MEETING WHERE THERE WERE
NOMINEES DETERMINED THAT SHOULD
EITHER SERVE ON THE SYSTEM
RIGHT COMMITTEE OR THE CAMPUS
COMMITTEE SO. OUR OUR STATUS AS
A FEW WAS PARTIALLY IMPLEMENTED
YOU SEE IT RECEIVING THOSE
REPORTS ON THE CAMPUSES BUT
WHAT WE NEED NOW TO SEE IS THE%
SYSTEM MIGHT COMMITTEE.
PAINFULLY FORMS AND THEN
REVIEWING THESE REPORTS AND
THEN PROVIDING FEEDBACK AND
GUIDANCE TO THE CAMPUSES. SO
THAT WAS ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT INCONSISTENCY WE STOCK OUR
STORES EXPECTATIONS. CAMPUSES
WITH RESPECT WORKING WITH THE
SECOND ISSUE TO THIS ARE THE
SAME RECORD REAL TO THIS ISSUE
AS WE WILL WE WILL TO SEE
UNIVERSAL THE OFFICE OF THE
SENATE INFORMING THE TRIBES
MAKING SURE THAT CAMPUSES ARE
PROPERLY INFORMING TRIBES ABOUT
ALL KNOWN MISSING REMAINS AND
ARTIFACTS- AND WE EXPECT THAT
TO BE DONE NO LATER THAN AUGUST
OF TWENTY TWENTY WE ISSUED A
REPORT IN JUNE OF TWENTY TWENTY
SO WE THOUGHT. IT A COUPLE OF
MONTHS- AND IF THE CAMPUS IS
HAVE THEM SO LET'S FIGURE OUT
AN APPROPRIATE WAY TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THOSE TRIBES.
THIS IS ONE OF THE-
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT MISTER
SALAS REFERRED TO THAT WE
CONSIDER FULL EMPLOYMENT BUT
I'M GOING TO ADD A LITTLE BIT
OF A COPY OUT TO THAT. WHAT
WE'RE SEEING IS UNIVERSITY
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT FIGURE
OUT WHICH CAMPUSES HAVE NOT
COMMUNICATE WITH TRIBES THEY
DID DO THAT THEY WENT THROUGH
AND LOOKED AT- EACH OF THE
CAMPUSES THAT HAVE ARTIFACTS
AND REMAINS HEADWAY
COMMUNICATED WITH PROJECTS TOO
MANY MISSING REMAINS ETCETERA.
THEY ARE ACTUALLY DETERMINE
THAT UC BERKELEY. WAS THE ONLY
CAMPUS THAT STILL NEEDED TO
COMMUNICATE. WITH THE
APPROPRIATE TRIBES IN THAT
REGION. AND SO THEY HAVE COME
UP WITH A PLAN TO DO SO PLAN TO
COMMUNICATE WESTERN WITH SEEING
ON THE APPROPRIATE PRICE WHAT
WE HAVEN'T SEEN. THE PARTY YOU
SEE KIDS HAVING IMPLEMENTED
THAT PLAN WE'VE SEEN THE PLAN
SEEMS REASONABLE- BUT NOW
YOU'VE GOT TO TAKE THOSE NEXT
STEPS AND IMPLEMENT THAT PLAN
AND WORK WITH. THE TRIBES
ASSOCIATED WITH WITH UC
BERKELEY- THAT WOULD HAVE.
REMAINS OR ARTIFACTS SO THAT
WAS THE FIRST KEY ISSUE IN THAT
COMMUNICATION WITH THE PRICE
SECOND IS WAS RE TO AND IS A
LITTLE BIT WILL AS I GO MY HIGH
WE LOOKED AT THE POLICY THE U.
ALL WITH REESE TO NAG AND THEY
TELL VERSION OF THAT AND AS YOU
MAY KNOW MEMBERS INTO EIGHTEEN
THE LEGISLATURE AMENDED CAL
NABRIT MACRO IN REQUIRED THE
UNIVERSITY TO DEVELOP CLEAR
TRANSPARENT SYSTEM WIDE
POLICIES AND THOSE NEEDED TO BE
DONE BY JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY
TWENTY. NOW OF THE UNIVERSITY
WAS ATTEMPTING TO DO THAT WAS
WORKING WITH ANY. H. C. THE
HERITAGE COMMISSION ERICA
HERITAGE COMMISSION THERE
COMMISSION ACTUALLY DISCUSS AND
THEIR ASK YOU SEE IT THE WAY
UNTIL JULY FIRST OF TWENTY
TWENTY SO THEY CAN PROVIDE
COMMENT BECAUSE THAT'S ONE AREA
WHERE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA HAS
NOT BEEN A GOOD JOB IS. SHARING
THAT DRAFT POLICY ALLOWING
TRIBES TO PROVIDE FEEDBACK AS
TO WHETHER OR NOT THEY WERE
COMFORTABLE WITH THE POLICY
WHETHER THERE NEEDED TO BE
MODIFICATIONS TO THE POLICY SO
YOU SEATED AGREED TO DELAY.
ISSUING THE FINAL POLICY UNTIL
JULY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY BUT
AGAIN THERE WERE ADDITIONAL
CONCERNS THAT THE TRIBES HAD-
SO THEY ENDED UP. ISSUING AN
INTERIM POLICY AND STILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH. THE
NATIONAL MERIT AND NATIVE
AMERICAN EXCUSE ME HERITAGE
COMMISSION ARE THEY STILL HAVE
NOT FINALIZED THE POLICY THERE
HAS BEEN COMMUNICATION BACK AND
FORTH. BETWEEN AN AGENCY AND-
YOU UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA- WE
JUST BELIEVE IN THIS ONE WE SAY
EXPANDING. BECAUSE THAT FINAL
POLICY HAS NOT BEEN ESTABLISHED
THERE HAS BEEN COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN YOU COP AND BUT AGAIN
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE THERE
NEEDS TO BE BETTER
COLLABORATION COMMUNICATION.
FROM THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
YOU AN AC TO ALLOW ANY SEAT
PROVIDE FEEDBACK WITH RESPECT
TO THAT POLICY WE HAD ISSUES
WITH THE POLICY THAT WAS
PUBLISHED IN JULY OF TWENTY
TWENTY THERE WAS NO
STANDARDIZED PROCESS FOR MAKING
AFFILIATION DECISIONS. THERE
WASN'T SIX SUFFICIENT OVERSIGHT
BY THE SYSTEM WHITE COMMITTEE
ON THE CAMPUSES WORK SUBMITTING
REGULAR REPORTS I JUST TALK
ABOUT THAT IT'S AGO SO IT'S
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
YES THIS POLICY FINALIZED SO
THAT YOU KNOW THIS IS
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
EXPECTATIONS ARE AND A H. C. IS
COMFORTABLE AND TRIED TO
CONQUER S. C. APPROACH GO
FORWARD THAT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S GOING TO USE. IN
WORKING WITH. THE TRUCK AND
MAKE SURE THAT PLEASE AND
ARTIFACTS AGAIN A RETURN TO
THEIR THEIR RIGHTS ALONE SO
THAT WAS THE SAN ISSUE IN THE
AUTHOR THIS ISSUE AND ALL THESE
ISSUES HOW TOGETHER THE THIRD
ISSUE THAT WE HAD WAS
MEMBERSHIP OFFICES WIDE CAMPUS
COMMITTEE AGAIN ALLOW CAT
AMENDED CALMAC THE VERSION OF
THE ACT AND REQUIRED THAT THESE
COMMITTEES BOTH CAMPUS
COMMUNITIES AND THAT'S WHY
COMMITTEES HAVE EQUAL
REPRESENTATION OF UNIVERSITY
MEMBERS AND TRIBAL MEMBERS.
FROM AND WHAT WE FOUND WHEN WE
CONDUCTED THE AUDIT ISSUED IN
JUNE OF TWENTY TWENTY THAT WAS
NOT THE CASE. IN FACT I UC
BERKELEY WAS PARTICULARLY
PROBLEMATIC BUT WE SAW PROBLEMS
WITH THE COMPOSITION OF THOSE
COMMITTEES AT EACH OF THE
CAMPUSES THAT WE LOOK AT SO
THIS WAS A SIGNIFICANT CONCERN
THAT WE HAVE- BECAUSE THE
UNIVERSE OF CALIFORNIA WAS NOT
COMPLYING WITH WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE'S INTENT WAS WHEN
IT MANDATE CAL MAG FOR. SO OUR
RECOMMENDATION WAS TO THE
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT YOU
NEED TO ENSURE THAT THE
MEMBERSHIP OF THE CAMPUS AND
SYSTEM WIDE COMMITTEES COMPLY
WITH STATE LAW AND YOU NEED TO
ACCOMPLISH. THAT BY NOVEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY. I THIS IS A
RECORD THAT'S BEEN I'M HERE CAL
AND WORK WITH THE NATIVE
AMERICAN HERITAGE COMMISSION
BECAUSE THE- COMMISSION
NOMINATES THOSE INDIVIDUALS TO
EITHER SERVE ON A CAMPUS
COMMITTEE OR SYSTEM WIDE
COMMITTEE- IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING BASED ON SOME OF
THE FEEDBACK WE RECEIVED FROM
THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA. THAT
THAT'S BEEN IT A DIFFICULT
PROCESS UNFORTUNATELY NHC HAS
HAD SOME. LOST SOME ELDERS FROM
THAT COMMITTEE- AND THEN THEY
HAD DIFFICULTY IN GETTING TO
MEET TOGETHER BUT AGAIN AS I AS
pUNDERSTANDING HELD A SPECIAL
MEETING IN JUNE. OF THIS YEAR
TO ACTUALLY COME UP WITH NAMES
OF INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD BE
NOMINEES FOR BOTH THE UC SYSTEM
WHITE COMMITTEE AND THE CAMPUS
COMMITTEE SO. THAT'S THE STATUS
WE YEAH WOULD DEFER TO YOU SEE
IF THEY HAVE MORE CURRENT
REGARDING SOME IS AS OF JUNE
TWENTY FOURTH EDITION ARE SO
AGAIN THERE NEEDS TO BE
PROGRESS BECAUSE THOSE THOSE
COMMUNITIES ARE SO IMPORTANT AS
FAR AS PROVIDING OVERSIGHT AND
GUIDANCE AT THE CAMPUS LEVEL
BUT CLEARLY AT THE AT THE
UNIVERSITY HEALTH WARNING ALSO
PRESENT LEVEL AT SYSTEM WIDE
COMMITTEES GETTING THESE- BUNNY
THE ANNUAL EVERY SIX MONTHS
REPORTS FROM THE CAMPUSES THAT
SYSTEM MIGHT COMMITTEE. NEEDS
THEY HAVE PROPER REPRESENTATION
SO THAT THE VOICE OF PRICES
FOR- AS WELL AS THE UNIVERSITY
MEMBERS WE SAW ON. THE
COMMITTEES WERE PRIMARILY
UNIVERSITY MEMBERS WE NEED TO
SEE MORE TRIBAL MEMBERS ARE FOR
THOSE COMMITTEES TO REPRESENT
WHAT THE LEGISLATURE EXPECTED
WHEN IT AMEND IT AKAUN ACTOR IN
BOTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
NINETEEN. SO THAT
RECOMMENDATION IS PENDING WE
NEED TO SEE SOME PROGRESS
PROGRESS THERE. AND THEN THE
LAST ISSUE- IS RELATED TO
PUBLICATION OF A LIST OF TRIBES
THAT CALIFORNIA RECOGNIZES AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROB. BE VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THIS BECAUSE HE
HAD ASSEMBLY BUILT UP TO
SEVENTY FIVE TO ADDRESS THIS.
ISSUE THERE WAS SIMPLY A
FEDERAL LEVEL- WHERE. THERE
WEREN'T THERE WOULD BE FEWER
TRIBES THAT WOULD BE ELIGIBLE.
TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROCESS-
BECAUSE OF THOSE FEDERAL
REGULATIONS IT WENT FROM EIGHTY
ONE TRIBES WORK CONDITIONING
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR
RECOGNITION DOWN TO FOUR SO IT
REALLY LIMITED THE OPPORTUNITY.
FOR TRIED TO CALIFORNIA TO BE
LUTON LAST ANSWER BE ENGAGE IN
THIS SEPARATE SO AB TWO SEVENTY
FIVE WAS IN STATUTES OF TWO. IT
MAN THAT THIRTY COMMISSION ARE
GENERATE LIST OF TRYING. ON THE
LIST OF RECORD CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES SO THAT
WAS ACCOMPLISHED AT BUILD
MISTER RAMOS WAS SUCCESSFUL WE
TO THE GOVERNOR WAS SOMETHING
IT WAS ENACTED INTO LAW SO
THAT'S A GREAT STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. ALSO IN THAT
LEGISLATION WAS A REQUIREMENT
THAT THE AMERICAN MISSION%
NOTIFY TRIED TO MUSEUMS AND
OTHER ENTITIES EXISTENCE OF
THIS LIST OF TRIBES AND THAT
WAS SUPPOSED TO BE DONE BY
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. IT WAS ACCOMPLISHED SO THE
NOTICE WENT OUT IN LATE
DECEMBER NEWS DECEMBER
THIRTIETH OR THIRTY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY BUT IT GOT DONE
SO THAT ACTUALLY- WAS
ACCOMPLISHED SO THIS
LEGISLATION CERTAINLY HAS HAD
AN IMPACT A VERY POSITIVE
IMPACT IN IN GETTING CALIFORNIA
IN IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION WITH
RESPECT TO RECOGNITION OF
TRIBES. AND CREATING THAT LIST
OF CALIFORNIA TRIBES SO THE
LAST RECOMMENDATION WAS- YOU TO
ENSURE THAT MORE TRIBES CAN
MAKE REPATRIATION CLAIMS AND H.
YOU SHOULD PUBLISH THIS LIST NO
LATER THAN SEPTEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY- IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING
THAT THE AC DID PUBLISHED ON
THEIR WEBSITE THE AVAILABILITY
OF THE LIST. AS I SAID THEY
THEY PUT A NOTICE IN DECEMBER
TWO AGENCIES MUSEUM STRIVES AT
CETERA ABOUT THE PROCESS TO
USED TO GAIN ACCESS TO THAT WE
GET THAT INFORMATION FROM THE
NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE
COMMISSION SO THE LEGISLATIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS FULLY
IMPLEMENTED AND REALLY HAS
AFFECTED SOME POSITIVE CHANGE
UP WHERE AGAIN WE NEED TO SEE
MORE PROGRESS IS. THE CREATION
OR THE COMPOSITION OF THE
SYSTEM WIDE CAMPUS COMMITTEES
YOU SEE NEEDS TO REALLY WORK
HARD IN THE NEXT FEW MONTHS TO
FINALIZE THAT. POLICY CONTINUE
TO READ WITH THE NATIVE
AMERICAN HERITAGE COMMISSION
GET THE STATE FROM THE TRIBES
OF THAT GET THAT PART FULLY
IMPLEMENT AND MY FINAL COMMON
THIS AUDIT WAS REQUIRED BY SEA
LAW HEALTH SAFETY CODE REQUIRED
US TO ISSUE CONDUCTING WATER.
THE FIRST ONE WAS SUPPOSED TO
COMPLIANCE AND TWENTY NINETEEN
WHICH FORCES THERE WE ISSUED A
REPORT IN JUNE OF TWENTY TWENTY
JUNE ELEVENTH TWENTY TWENTY SO
WE HAVE A FULL ONE YEAR
RESPONSE THAT I'VE BEEN
REFERRING TO. AND IT ALSO THE
STATUTE ALSO REQUIRES US TO
COMMENCE THE SECOND AUDIT IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WE CAN DO
THAT WHAT I WOULD PROPOSE AND
TO THE MEMBERS YES I WOULD I
THINK IT WOULD BE IMPORTANT FOR
MY OFFICE TO WAIT A FEW MONTHS
SO PROBABLY NOT START. UNTIL
DECEMBER OR MAYBE EVEN JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY TWO IF YOU SEE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH AN
AGENCY BECAUSE THEY HAVE THIS
RECENT MEETING IN GERMANTOWN
NOMINATE INDIVIDUALS FOR THOSE
COMMITTEES LET'S GIVE THAT A
LITTLE BIT OF TIME- AND IF WE
START SOMETHING SAY IN JANUARY
OF NEXT YEAR WE WOULD BE ABLE
TO ISSUE IT. IN JUNE OF TWENTY
TWENTY OF WHICH WOULD BE A TWO
YEAR CYCLES SO THE LEGISLATURE
SEEM THE INTENT WAS STARTED NOT
IN TENTY NINETEEN STAR NOT IN
SO IF WE IF WE GET SOMETHING
ISSUED BY JUNE OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. I THINK THAT WOULD MAKE
SENSE THAT GIVES YOU SEE
SOMETIMES IT GIVES THE
COMMISSION THE TRIBES AND THEN
WE WOULD HAVE HOPEFULLY
INFORMATION IN THAT IN THAT
NEXT AUDIT REPORT THAT SHOWS
THAT YOU KNOW FULL
IMPLEMENTATION HAS OCCURRED OF
ALL THESE RECOMMENDATIONS. AND
PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE
PARTICULAR UC BERKELEY TO GET
THESE ARTIFACTS AND REMAINS ARE
REPATRIATED. TO THE APPROPRIATE
TRIBES SO WITH THAT MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND CHAIR SALAS WILL
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU OR
OTHER MEMBERS MAY HAVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
THAT- AUDIT REPORT- COMING
FORWARD ON THE PROGRESS OF
THIS- THE IMPORTANT TOPIC IS
THERE ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WISHING TO. SEND. COMMENTS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DINA THANK YOU
A MISTER CHAIR YES TO THE STATE
I I'M I'M LOOKING HERE MY NOTES
SUMMER OF THE AUDIT AND ON THE
FIRST PAGE IS SAYS SOME
CAMPUSES A RETURN LARGER
PORTIONS OF REMAINS AND
ARTIFACTS IN THEIR-
COLLECTIONS. TO TRIBES SO I'M
LOOKING AT IT IT SAYS SOME
CAMPUSES AND SO THERE WERE
THREE CAMPUSES CORRECT THREE
THREE CAMPUSES THAT WERE ADDED.
AND JUST CORRECT YEAH SO FOR MY
CLARIFICATION- CAN CAN YOU JUST
BE CLEAR FOR ME WHICH WHICH
CAMPUSES ARE DOING A BETTER JOB
THAN OTHERS. YES THIS IS JIM
ADAMS THE AUDIT SUPERVISOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AT LOS
ANGELES HAS HAD THE MOST
SUCCESS IN THE PAST TREATING
IT- NATIVE AMERICAN REMAINS AND
ARTIFACTS. IT'S BEEN ABLE TO
RETURN THOSE TWO TRIBES I THINK
IT'S A MORE THAN 90% OF THE
ITEMS AND REMAINS THAT IT HAD-
STORED IN ITS COLLECTION OF ITS
MUSEUM- UC DAVIS WAS ANOTHER
CAMPUS THAT WE REVIEWED THAT
HAD MADE SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS
PARTICULARLY OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS IN RETURNING REMAINS AND
ARTIFACTS TO TRIBES. WHEN YOU
TELL ME WHAT I WOULD PERCENT
DAVIS HAS DONE YOU SAID UCLA.
HAD RETURNED 90% THE ARTIST
FIRST S. C. I CAN FIND OUT OF
IN OUR OUR AUTO REPORT QUICK IF
YOU WITH ME FROM SURE WELL USE
DAVIS HAD A JUST A 2% RAISE
RATE WE DID NOTE THAT THERE WAS
A PARTICULAR COLLECTION THAT
THEY HAD THAT HAD OVER FORTY
THOUSAND ITEMS THAT THEY'VE
BEEN WORKING TO RETURNS. I
TRIED THAT- IS IN THE
SACRAMENTO AREA- AND SO IF WE-
KIND OF TAKE OUT THAT THAT THAT
LARGE- COLLECTION THERE- THEY
HAD- REPATRIATED ABOUT 89% 89%
OKAY AND THEN IF YOU I'M SORRY
TO INTERRUPT SO IF. YOU WOULD
CONTINUE WITH. BERKELEY YES SO
BERKELEY. TRYING TO COMPLY WITH
NIAGARA AND RETURNING THE
REMAINS OF THE TRIBE'S NAME
ONLY HAS ABOUT 19% OF THE
REMAINS AND ARTIFACTS IN ITS
COLLECTION OKAY AND I HAVE BEEN
AWARE OF THIS ISSUE- PROBABLY-
GOING BACK MAYBE THREE OR FOUR
YEARS I WAS AT UC REGENTS
MEETING WHERE- TRAVEL CHAIR
FROM THE CHUNGA CURRENT
ADDRESSED. THE THE UC REGENTS
SO WHAT WOULD YOU TELL ME. AS
SOMEONE WHO'S VERY INTERESTED
IN THIS MATTER WHAT WHAT IS
KEEPING BERKELEY FROM DOING A
BETTER JOB. AS COMPARED TO UCLA
AND UC DAVIS SURE MISTER MEDINA
AND I'LL AND I'LL DEFER TO
MISTER ADAMS AND MAN ONE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE WITH YOU
BERKELEY'S ROACH IS THAT OVER
EXPECTING TRIBES TO PROVIDE
MUCH MORE EVIDENCE THAN OTHER
UCLA OR UC DAVIS ALSO- WITH
THREE STATUS WORK WITH RESPECT
TO AFFILIATION AND THEN THERE'S
A DISPOSITION JUST A DIFFERENT
PROCESS AND THAT ONE IS ISN'T
INVOLVES COMMUNICATION WITH THE
DIFFERENT TRIBES SO REACHING
OUT TO A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
TRIBES HI JERRY TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT. THEY ARE
AFFILIATED OR OR ASSOCIATED
WITH IT OF THOSE THREE ARE AND
WHAT WE SAW THAT YOU SEE BURKE
IS AND MORE STRINGENT PROCESS
THEY WERE EXPECTING STUFF THEY
REACHED OUT TO FIFTEEN TRIBES
THEY WERE WAITING TO HEAR BACK
IN WRITING. FROM EACH AND EVERY
ONE OF THOSE TRIED BEFORE THEY
WERE WILLING TO MOVE FORWARD IN
THE PROCESS AND WE FELT THAT
THAT WAS VERY STRINGENT. NOW
AGAIN I THINK THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA THEY ALSO PRESENT
NEEDS TO GET THAT POLICY WITH
RESPECT TO FOLLOW THIS.
REPATRIATION ACT IS GOING TO BE
CARRIED OUT OUT THERE SO THAT
THERE IS CONSISTENCY FROM ONE
CAMPUS TO ANOTHER BECAUSE I
THINK BERKELEY. IS BEING MUCH
MORE RESTRICTIVE ON MAKING IT
MUCH MORE DIFFICULT FOR TRIBES
TO ENGAGE IN THIS PROCESS AND
FOR THOSE REMAINS AND ARTIFACTS
SHOULD BE RETURNED TO THEIR
RIGHTFUL OWNERS BUT I'LL I'LL
ASK HIM IF HE HAS ANY OTHER
ADDITIONAL CONTENT AND AGAIN
WHILE OTHER CAMPUSES HAVE.
CLOSE 290% BERKELEY. IS ONLY
WHERE AT WHAT ARE APPROXIMATELY
NINE TWENTY FIRST HAS A TINY
FOR. OF OUT THE RETURNING WHAT
WHAT NEEDS TO BE RETURNED RIGHT
AND THEY SIGNIFICAN THEY HAVE A
VERY LARGE COLLECTION SO THERE
ARE A LOT OF REMAINS AND
ARTEFACTS AT UC BERKELEY STILL
AT LEAST AT THE TIME WE
CONDUCTED THE AUDIT LAST YEAR I
STILL HAVE IN ITS INVENTORY
THAT IT NEEDS TO REALLY WORK
VERY HARD AND RETURNING THOSE
THOSE ARTIFACTS AND REMAINS- WE
NEED TO SEE MUCH BETTER
PROGRESS. WITH UC BERKELEY AND
IT IF YOU COPY YOU KNOW REALLY
FOCUSES AS WE SAID THERE'S THAT
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN THAT THEY
DEVELOPED RELATED TO MISSING
REMAINS BAKER PLAN TOGETHER BUT
AGAIN WE DON'T KNOW WHETHER
THAT PLANS MEDICAL MINUTES SO I
THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE A LOT
OF FOCUS AND ATTENTION ON YEARS
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY HOW TO
IMPROVE THEIR PROCESS. TO START
GETTING THESE REMAINS AND
ARTIFACTS RETURNED. ONTO THE
APPROPRIATE TRIBES AND PERHAPS
THE CHAIR I DO WALKED IN HIS
UNIVERSE COLLEGE THE
REPRESENTED HERE IN THIS AREA
YEAH IT WILL HAVE A PRESENCE IN
THE NEXT TO A-SECTION. FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF PROVOSTS ON
MICHAEL BROWN AND RANDY KATZ
VICE CHANCELLOR OF RESEARCH AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
WILL HAVE A CHANCE TO HEAR FROM
YOU SEE AND- WHAT THEY CAN'T DO
BETTER. THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
THOSE- QUESTIONS ANY OTHER
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF
SALAS GERMAN SONGS AT THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN RAMOS JUST QUICK
QUESTION THAT THEY CAN BETTER
MONITOR FOR YOU AND YOUR TEAMS
WORK ON THIS AND FOR THE FOLLOW
UP NOW. BUT LOOKING AT THE
AUDIT YOU KNOW YOU FOUND THAT
ONLY ONE OF THE THREE CAMPUSES
PRESENTS CLAIMS TO THE CAMPUS
LEVEL COMMITTEE THAT ADVISES-
MACRA IMPLEMENTATION ALL THREE
CAMPUSES YOU KNOW HAVE THESE
COMMITTEES BUT ONLY ONE USE THE
ENTIRE COMMITTEE TO OVERSEE AND
APPROVE REQUESTS SO THE
QUESTION REALLY IS YOU KNOW-
WHY WHY DID ONLY ONE CAMPUS
HE'S HE'S NOT THE OTHERS I KNOW
YOU MENTIONED AND- AND YOUR
BRIEFING EARLIER THE
INCONSISTENCIES. BUT WAS THERE
ANYTHING THAT LED YOU TO
UNDERSTAND WHY THIS WAS ONLY
IMPLEMENTED FOR ON CAMPUS
COMMITTEES WAS ONLY DONE AT UC
DAVIS YES THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION THE UC DAVIS CAMPUS
SNAPPER POLICY REQUIRED THEIR
CAMPUS SNAPPER COMMITTEE TO
REVIEW THESE DECISIONS THEIR
INSULAR BY CHANCE I'M NOT
ENTIRELY SURE WHAT THE
STRUCTURE IS A ON HOW THEY WANT
THEIR THEIR MUSEUM BUT THERE
SUPERVISORS DECIDED TO UPDATE
THEIR KNACK FOR POLICY AT THE
CAMPUS LEVEL IN A WAY THAT
PROVIDED GREATER BY AND FOR
THAT COMMITTEE AND TRIBES THAT
WERE ON THAT COMMITTEE SO THE
EACH OF THE CAMPUSES HAVE THEIR
OWN- NETWORK POLICY AND THE TWO
OTHER CAMPUSES THAT WE WORK YOU
DIDN'T INCLUDE THAT KIND OF
STUFF IN THERE IN THE REVIEW
PROCESS. AND WITH THE SIDE OF
THROUGH THE CHAIR BUT- NOW THAT
WE'RE DOING THE ONE YEAR FOLLOW
UP DID YOU FIND THE OTHER CAMPS
IS NOW MOVING TOWARDS TOWARDS
COMPLETING THEIR ON CAMPUS
COMMITTEES TO ONE FULFILL THEM
I COMPLETELY SO THERE'S EQUAL
REPRESENTATION AND TO. JUST
FURTHER IMPLEMENTING THE CAMPUS
LEVEL COMMITTEES. I THINK THAT
GOES BACK TO THE STATE
AUDITOR'S DISCUSSION OFTHE
DELAY IN NOMINATIONS AND
FILLING THOSE COMMITTEES SO
WE'LL DEFER TO THE YOU SEE THE-
RESPONSIBLE YEAH MANY WALLACE
AS I INDICATED. THEY THEY
CAMPUS COMMITTEES IN THE SYSTEM
LIKE COMMITTEE ARE OUR RELIANCE
FIRST TRIBAL MEMBERS. TO GET
NOMINEES FROM THE NATIVE
AMERICAN HERITAGE COMMISSION AS
I SAID THEY JUST RECENTLY HAD A
MEETING OUR SPECIAL MEETING
ACTUALLY HELD A SPECIAL MEETING
IS A NEW HOMEPORT THIS WAS IN
JUNE OF THIS YEAR COUPLE OF
MONTHS AGO. TO NOMINATE
INDIVIDUALS AND THAT'S WHY IT
THIS IS DURING MY COMMENTS THE
UNIVERSITY OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT REALLY NEEDS TO MOVE
VERY QUICKLY NOW TO TRY TO GET
INDIVIDUALS APPOINTED TO THE
SYSTEM WHITE COMMITTEE AND
THOSE CAMPUS MAYES AND YOU CRAP
NEEDS TO MAKE SURE THOSE CAMPUS
COMMITTEES ARE PROVIDING THE
PROPER OVERSIGHT. OVER THIS
PROCESS OF REPATRIATING REMAINS
AND ARTIFACTS SO THE NEXT VERY
IMPORTANT STEP IS TO GET THOSE.
COMMITTEES- I STAFF NOT AS BUT
FULLY FORMED AND THAT THEY HAVE
PROPERTY REPRESENT AS X. BY THE
LEGISLATURE THERE NEEDS TO
EQUAL OF NEW MEMBERS OF TRIBAL
MEMBERS AND THAT'S GOING TO BE
IN A VERY IMPORTANT NEXT STEP
IF IT HASN'T HAPPENED YET.
AGAIN THE NOMINATIONS- WERE
VOTED DOWN AYE MY UNDERSTANDING
IN JUNE BY THAT. MISSION SO
WE'VE GOT TO MOVE IN THAT
DIRECTION I THINK UC DAVIS I MR
ADAM WAS INDICATING WAS
SOMEWHAT MORE PROACTIVE THAN
OTHER CAMPUSES. BUT AGAIN. WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT THE OFFICE OF
THE PRESIDENT NEEDS TO GET THAT
POLICY DONE THEY NEED TO GET
THOSE COMMITTEES FULLY FORMED
FULLY REPRESENTATIVE- SO THAT
THEY CAN MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
PROCESS SO. OVERSIGHT OVER. THE
DECISION MAKING AND THE
COLLABORATION COMMUNICATION
WITH TRIBES SO I THINK THOSE
ARE THE IMPORTANT NEXT STEPS
THAT NEED TO HAPPEN THANK YOU
BETER MONITOR LOOK FORWARD TO
THE UC'S RESPONSE ON THAT AS
WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS ANY
OTHER MEMBERS. HELLO THANK YOU
FOR OF YOUR PRESENTATION- STATE
AUDITOR ELAINE HOLLAND JIM
ADAMS- FOR YOUR YOUR- OVERALL
PER VIEW OF THESE THINGS AND
LAYING OUT THE GROUNDWORK FOR
THE NEXT STEPS OF HOW WE
CONTINUE TO- INSURE THAT THE
PROVINCE'S HAPPENING. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THAT AT THIS TIME
WE'RE GONNA MOVE FORWARD AND
CALL THE NEXT- PANEL UP. AND
THIS IS THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SYSTEM- PRESENTERS
WILL BE- UNIVERSITY PROVOST
MICHAEL BROWN AND RANDY KATZ
VICE CHANCELLOR OF RESEARCH AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY DO WE HAVE THEM ON THE
LINE. ORANGE- NO NO MRE ARE OUT
OF TOWN CAN EVERYONE HEAR ME WE
HEAR YOU GREATER VALUE. RIGHT
SHOULD I JUST START UP AS THE
CHAIR. RAMOS YES YES PLEASE
THIS IS A GREAT PROVOST MICHAEL
BROWN GOOD AT SHERA AND MEMBERS
THE CAL ASSEMBLY SALAH
COMMITTEE ON AMERICAN FOR- ALSO
WANT TO GROW THAT I WILL TRIBAL
REP MIGHT BE HERE ARE LISTENING
AT IN THE CERTAINLY WANT TO.
HONOR OUR CAL STATE OUT OF AND
OTHER A RESPECTED HE I MICHAEL
BROWN PROVO AND VICE PRESIDENT
FOR ACADEMIC AFFAIRS AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA ARE IN
THE OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT AND
I'M HAPPY. TO BE BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE AGAIN I KNOW- THE
GOAL OF THIS COMMITTEE IS TO
PRESS THE UNIVERSITY FOR
ACTION. I WELCOME SO- I WISH IT
WASN'T NECESSARY CAN WE WANT TO
MOVE AGGRESSIVELY- AS WE CAN TO
MAKE IT LESS NECESSARY IN THE
FUTURE OUR BUT I UNDERSTAND
HISTORY I WANT YOU TO KNOW THE
PRESIDENT HAS TASKED ME WITH
LEADING THE UNIVERSITY'S
REPATRIATION EFFORTS AND IT IS
A COMBAT BONTA UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA TO WORK. TO REPAIR
RELATIONS BETWEEN THE
UNIVERSITY AND CALIFORNIA
TRIBES I. AM COMMITTED TO DOING
SO I FULLY ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE
MUST MAKE GOOD ON OUR
COMMITMENT TO MORE EFFECTIVE
AND RESPECTFUL REPATRIATION
UNDER FEDERAL NAGLA AND CAL
KNACK FOR. A TO THIS END YOU
SEEM TED AN INTERIM POLICY ON
JULY TWENTIETH THAT WAS CORRECT
PLEASE REFERRED TO A BAR. AND
HAD THAT INCORPORATES TRIBAL
FEEDBACK THAT WE HAD RECEIVED
THE POLICY WAS ISSUED AS INTRO-
TO ALLOW TRIBES THAT HAD NOT
BEEN ABLE TO COMMENT I DO TOO
COLD AT NINETEEN AND ALL THAT
ISSUES AROUND THAT- IN OUR
PANDEMIC. ARE AND ACT AND TO
ALLOW ADDITIONAL TIME THROUGH
AT THAT TIME NOVEMBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY- BUT BASED ON. THOSE
COMMENTS IN INCORPORATING THE
CHANGES COUNT CAL NETWORK THAT
ON AB AT SEVENTY FIVE WE WERE
THE FOURTH DAY ALL THE- OF FOR
REVIEW BY TRY IN YOU SEE COME
ON IN MY OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WITH A NINETY DAY. COMMENT
PERIOD WE HAVE PORED OVER
HUNDREDS OF WRITTEN AND ORAL
COMMENTS AND AFTER ADDITIONAL
CON A CONSULTATION WITH AN AGE
THING WE HOPE TO RELEASE THAT
FINAL POLICY WITHIN THE NEXT
COUPLE WEEKS I WILL MENTION-
KINDA HOT OFF THE PRESS- I MET.
WITH OUR PERSONS IN MY OFFICE
WITH IN AGENCY LEADERSHIP JUST
YESTERDAY AT TO WORK THROUGH. A
PROCESS FOR CLOSING GAPS AS- AS
THIS COMMITTEE I UNDERSTAND AND
I KNOW APPRECIATES IN THE
COURAGE IS THE UNIVERSITY
ACTUALLY HAVE BETTER
COLLABORATIVE RELATIONSHIPS
WITH NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES THE UNIVERSE CAN'T
JUST ACT ON ITS OWN HERE AND-
OUT THAT COLLABORATION- LIKE A
LOT OF COLLABORATIONS DOES TAKE
TIME BUT I DO WANT TO. THANK
THE NHS FOR THEIR PARTNERSHIP
HERE AND I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED R. AT DIFFERENT
THAN THE PREVIOUS POLICY THE
CURRENT POLICY EXPRESSES A
CLEAR PURPOSE VISION GUIDING
PRINCIPLES I BET PRIORITIZE
REPATRIATION AS A FUNDAMENTAL
OBJECTIVE AND VALUE OF THE
UNIVERSITY- WE BELIEVE WE'RE
MAKING PROGRESS. UNDER THE
INTERIM POLICY AND DOING WHAT
WE CAN ABOUT- AS YOU HEARD FROM
THE AUDITOR AT THE KEY TO. OUR
MORE AGGRESSIVE ACTION IS THOSE
COMMITTEES BEING PUT TOGETHER
WE THANK PUBLICLY I WOULD FORTY
THANK PRIVATE BEFORE THEY COULD
PUBLICLY. I B. NH C. FOR THE AT
THE REC FOR A COMMITTEE MEMBER
HAVE THAT I TOOK PLACE I JUNE
TWENTY FOURTH OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE DOES COMMIT ARE BEING PUT
TOGETHER I'M HAPPY TO SAY ARE
ITS PRIME RIB TO ME THAT SEE A
AND BERKELEY HAVE PUT THEIR
COMMITTEES TOGETHER AND THE
OTHER CAMPUSES ARE MOVING
AGGRESSIVELY AND AT IN THAT
VEIN- I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A FEW
IMPORTANT ASPECTS OF THE
POLICY- THE POLICY REQUIRES
REEVALUATION OF PREVIOUS
DETERMINATIONS. OF CULTURALLY
ON IDENTIFIABLE HUMAN REMAINS
REMAINS ARE ARE ASSOCIATIVE IN
MEMORY ARE OBJECTS I THINK THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT ASPECT OF THIS
POLICY AND IT HAS TO BE DONE
NOW IN CONSULTATION WITH NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBES AND THAT LINKS
TO A NOTHER- IMPORTANT
EVOLUTION AND POLICY THAT I
MENTIONED A LITTLE LATER- THE
POLICY INCLUDES MANDATORY.
TRIBAL CONSULTATION AND TRIBAL
APPROVAL FOR ACCESS TO HUMAN
REMAINS AND CULTURAL ITEMS I'M
NOT NOT EVERYONE CAN JUST GET
ACCESS TO THESE REMAINS OUT WE
WANT TO TREAT THAT PROCESS WE
WANT TO KNOW WHO HAS ACCESS AND
WANT TO TREAT THAT PROCESS
RESPECTFULLY AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE TRY. THE
ASSOCIATED TRIBES- NO- AND ARE
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT ACCESS
AND AS YOU KNOW- OUT FOR THE
RESEARCHER- STRUCTURALLY OTHER
PURPOSE- IS CONSTRAINED WITH
OUT THAT APPROVAL- BYE. BY
TRANS THE POLICY ALSO REQUIRES
RECONSTITUTION AS THE ARTERY
INDICATED- OF THE SYSTEM MY
COMMITTEE AND CAMPUS COMMITTEE
STUDENT CALLED EQUAL
REPRESENTATION A NATIVE
AMERICAN AND- AND YOU SEE.
REPRESENTATION AND THAT AS WELL
ON ITS WAY BUT I AGREE OUT- OUT
WE WILL PICK THE PACE WE NEED
TO PAY UP THE PACE I AM I HAPPY
THAT IT'S HAPPENING- BUT- WE DO
NEED TO ACTUALLY SHOW THE
PROGRESS. AFTER OUR RECENTLY
RECEIVING THOSE NOMINATIONS- I
DO THINK- THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO
SHOW THAT THERE IS SOME OF THE
COMMITTEES ARE THAT THE
COMMITTEES ARE EXPECTED TO TAKE
A MUCH MORE PRO ACTIVE ROLE
THEY WILL NOT JUST READ ACT A
TO- WHEN CIRCUMSTANCES OCCUR
THAT REQUIRE THE INVOLVEMENT
THERE ACTUALLY ARE TASKED NOW
BY THE POLICY- EVEN IN ITS
INTERIM SPATE S. STATE TO BE
VERY AGGRESSIVE. ABOUT DOING
ALL THEY CAN TO ADVANCE
REPATRIATION ACTIVITIES THE
INTERIM POLICY BETTER HONORS
AND DAHLE USE TRIBAL ORAL
HISTORIES AND SOURCES OF
EVIDENCE. SOMETIMES THAT'S THE
ONLY EVIDENCE THAT WE AVE AND
AND TO BETTER HONOR THAT WILL
HELP WITH RESPECT TO CULTURAL
IDENTIFICATION AND REPATRIATION
WE BELIEVE THAT I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT A SINGLE NOW
LONG EVIDENCE- AND THAT MIGHT
BE A TRIBAL OR HISTORIES- AT
THAT THAT WOULD BE ABOUT. TO
ESTABLISH CULTURAL AFFILIATION
ACT- AND- AND SO WE HOPE THAT
THAT MAKES A BIG DIFFERENCE
GOING FORWARD IN ACCORDANCE TO
A. B. AT WITH EIGHTY TWO
SEVENTY FIVE THE LATEST DRAFT
OF THE POLICY EXPLICITLY
REQUIRES DEFERENCE TO TRIBAL
TRADITIONAL KNOWLEDGE. SO ALL
CAMPUS REPATRIATION
COORDINATORS PRESENTLY CONDUCT
THEIR WORK AND ARE PREPARING.
FOR CAL MAG WOULD REQUIRE OUR
INVENTORY AND WITH THE
PRINCIPLES ARE MIND I I'LL WITH
MY TO I ET A MYSELF WITH THE
PREACHER CORN TO. THAT POINT
I'VE ALSO MET WITH THE
CHANCELLOR'S DESIGNATED ARE
LEADS ON ON ON REPATRIATION
ACTIVITIES AT TO EMPHASIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS PRIORITY THE
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN COORDINATING TWICE MONTHLY
MEETINGS WITH ALL CAMPUS
REPATRIATION COORDINATORS AND
POINTS OF CONTACT THIS ALLOWS
FOR NORMALIZATION ACROSS THE
CAMPUSES THE SHARING OF BEST
PRACTICES BUT THE SYSTEM LIKE
COMMITTEE WILL ALSO BE KEY TO
THAT AS THE ARDOR POINTED OUT I
AGREE. AND GETTING THAT
COMMITTEE UP AND RUNNING I'LL
OUT IS OUT FULLY UP AND RUNNING
IS OF HARPER- I'M PORTANT LATE
AS REQUIRED BY THE POLICY ALL
CAMPS ARE. INITIATING CAMPUS
WIDE SEARCHES FOR ANY
PREVIOUSLY UNREPORTED HOLDING
THAT MAY POTENTIALLY CONTAIN
NATIVE AMERICAN REMAINS
CULTURAL ITEMS ETHNOGRAPHIC OR
ARCHAEOLOGICAL OBJECTS LET ME
SAY. THAT EIGHT GRIEVES ME- AT
THAT SUCH OUR ARMED OUT ITEMS
ANCESTORS MAY BE DISCOVERED BY
THIS PROCESS BECAUSE WE
WOULDN'T WANT IT- AS THOSE ALL
TO HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED. AHEAD
OF TIME BUT AS MUCH AS A ME
ABOUT THAT I AM ALL JOIN THAT
WE DO WANT COVER CIRCUMSTANCES
WHERE OF WHERE OUR REMAINS ARE
ARE OTHER CULTURAL ITEMS ARE
FOUND AND DISCOVERED AND- HI
AND SO IT'S A IT'S A
BITTERSWEET SITUATION FOR ME
BUT I'D MUCH RATHER ON HOWEVER
THE REMAINS. AND CREEK EIGHT
THIS NEW OPPORTUNITY TO RETURN
THE ANCESTORS- AT AT THEIR
PEOPLE AND TO RESPECTFUL
REINTERMENT- ARE AS PAINFUL AS
THAT MIGHT BE R. I AM CURRENTLY
AND- AND I WANT TO SAY OUR
PRESIDENT TO SO I DON'T WANT TO
BREAK MY ARM HERE TRYING TO PUT
MYSELF ON THE BACK WE ARE
AGGRESSIVELY SEEK OUR INTERNAL
FUNDING OUR RESOURCES TO
FURTHER THIS WORK. I WANT TO
STATE BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE
IT'S NOT JUST THE UNIVERSITY BY
THE WAY THAT NEEDS OUR
RESOURCES TO EFFECT. AND THE
BLUE ROUTE REPATRIATION PROCESS
MANY OF OUR TRIBES. DUE TO
THEIR NOT ALL I DON'T HAVE A
RESOURCE AND- I NOT A ONLY BE
IMPRESSED WITH ALL THE REVIEWS
I'VE GONE. THROUGH AROUND THE
STATE AND MEETING WITH TRIBAL
PEOPLES HOW IMPORTANT-
RESOURCES AND PLACES TO RE
ENTER HOW IMPORTANT THAT IS AND
SO I JUST WANT TO MENTION- AS I
MENTIONED ALL CAMPUSES ARE ARE
ARE MOVING. FORWARD AND I WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT SOME THINGS FOR
THIS COMMITTEE BUT I DO WANT TO
SAY I UNDERSTAND THERE'S MORE
TO BE DONE HERE SO PLEASE DON'T
HEAR THIS LESS AS SOMEHOW
SAYING THAT. THAT HE
UNIVERSITY- I HAVE TO DO THAT
SO I THINK YOU'VE GOT WAYS TO
GO HERE BUT I DO WANT TO SAY
I'M SEEING PROGRESS. IN PLEASE
ALLOW ME TO STOCKPILE. SO UC
DAVIS REPEATED RECORD PATRIOTA
FORTY FIVE SETS OF INDIVIDUAL
ANCESTRAL HUMAN REMAINS IN OVER
FORTY ONE THOUSAND. FUNERARY
OBJECTS TO JACKSON RANCH HERE
TO REACT SHINGLE SPRINGS BAND
OF MIWOK INDIANS AND- YOUR
COULD DEDICATE OUR LENTEN
NATION. IN ADDITION AS MANY
TRIBES AT AS MANY TRIES A BIG
SPREAD ACCESS TO APPROPRIATE.
AND SECURE WITH BURIAL LAND AS
A BERRY TO REPATRIATION UC
DAVIS. HAS SUCCESSFULLY-
FACILITATED GREEN THAT'S
ALLOWING OUR TRIBES TO CONDUCT
WITH VARIAS ON CAMPUS AND
PRIVATE LIFE THAT'S NOT. THE
CASE THAT CAN'T BE THE CASE
THAT EVERY CAMPUS BUT I. AM
WORKING ON AND FIND RESPECTFUL
THAT COULD BE. I FOR THE
RESPECTIVE RE OF A FOR NAY I'M
TRIBES DON'T HAVE A LAND TO
REINTERPRET I'M I IN AUGUST OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE UC DAVIS WAS
AWARDED A NATIONAL MAXPREPS
CONSULTATION DOCUMENTATION
GRANT FROM THE NATIONAL PARK
SERVICE THE GRANT OF A WRITTEN
COOPERATION WITH THE TRIBAL
PARK WILL ALLOW THE UNIVERSITY
FOR THE LEVERAGES RESOURCES AND
ACCELERATE REPATRIATION
PRODUCT- PROGRESS FOR FORESIGHT
IN THE NAPA AND SOLANO. SOLANO
COUNTY UCLA WORKING WITH
CONTROLLING AGENCIES TO
FACILITATE REPATRIATION IS
COMPLETELY A REPATRIATION OF
HUMAN REMAINS AND FUNERARY
OBJECTS TO THE PIE YOU INDIAN
TRIBE OF UTAH HI IN MARCH OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND UC
RIVERSIDE HAS COMPLETED AN
INITIAL SH SORTING AND
CATALOGING OVER FIVE THOUSAND.
CARBON SAMPLES FROM ITS NOW
DEFUNCT RADIOCARBON LABORATORY
FINDINGS SEVENTY EIGHT SAMPLES
CONTAINING HUMAN REMAINS SIXTY
TWO OF THOSE SAMPLES HAVE BEEN
I RETURN TO THE CONTROLLING
INSTITUTIONS- SO THOSE
INSTITUTIONS COULD BEGIN THE
PROCESS OF REPATRIATION AND
OTHERS ARE IN PROGRESS BUT I
WANT TO SAY YOU SEE OUR WILL
INITIATE CONSULTATIONS ON AT
LEAST FOUR SAMPLES FOR WHICH
YOU SEE DOES HAVE CONTROL UC
SANTA BARBARA. IS ENGAGED IN
ONGOING DISCUSSIONS WITH
MULTIPLE BAND OF THE CHUMASH
PEOPLE LET ME ACKNOWLEDGE THAT-
I'M HERE IN SANTA BARBARA- ON
ON NATIVE- IN HISTORICAL TO MAX
LINE- AB THE THEY CAN'T IS
WORKING TO MY PEOPLE OUR OF IN
OVER OF ALSO WARY A LOCATED ON
CAMPUS AND GET INVENTORY. I HAD
TO- ADD TO RELATIONSHIP
BUILDING- OUT FOR THE PURPOSES
OF REPATRIATION HI ADDITIONALLY
YOU SEE STAFF HAVE MET WITH-
THE REPOSITORY TO MASTER VISOR
COMMITTEE TO DISCUSS THE
REPATRIATION PROCESS AND TO
HEAR RECEIVE AND ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS. I DO WANT TO MENTION
THAT YOU SEE SAN DIEGO AS
RECENTLY AS JULY THE TWENTY I.
TWENTY ONE HAS HIRED A FULL
TIME. AND MEDICAL COORDINATOR
WHO HAS EXTENSIVE EXPERIENCE IN
REPATRIATION ISSUES AND
CONSULTING WITH TRIBES LOCAL TO
THE SAN DIEGO AREA THAT CAMPUS
IS IN COMMUNICATION WELL MORE
THAN SIXTY TRIALS REGARDING
ANCESTRAL REMAINS CULTURAL
ITEMS FEW- FLORAL AND FAUNA
REMAINS ASSOCIATED. WITH A
FORMER- ECS AT LEAST FACTORED
IN THERE. AND YOU SEE S. C. L.
A. HAS COMPLETED AT THE LEGAL
TRANSFER OF HUMAN REMAINS
TEHAMA MOODS AND I TRAVEL BAN
REBURIAL IS PENDING THE
RESUMPTION OF CAMPUS AND TRIBAL
OPERATIONS THAT HAD BEEN ON
HOLD DUE TO PANDEMIC. AND I
KNOW YOU WILL HAVE SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS- FOR A UC BERKELEY
VICE CHANCELLOR HI RANDY KATZ
BUT IF THERE ARE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR THAT
I COULD ADDRESS I'M HAPPY TO DO
SO NOW. A QUESTIONS- FOR THE
PROS. YEAH CAROUSELS THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR I REMEMBER
HEARING YOU WERE EXT YOUR AND
WILLINGNESS TO ACTUALLY RESOLVE
A LOT OF THESE THINGS THESE
THESE MATTERS OF THESE ITEMS AB
ONE I DIDN'T HEAR YOUR RESPONSE
MAYBE YOU CAN HELP ELABORATE.
IS OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
OUTLINED IN THE AUDIT A
TIMELINE ON WHEN THOSE WILL BE
FULLY IMPLEMENTED- WE KNOW ONCE
FULLY IMPLEMENTED BUT WE'RE
STILL HAVE FOR THAT ARE
PENDING. AND I KNOW YOUR
COMMITMENTS LIKE YOU'VE- STATED
IS THERE TO RESOLVE THESE
ISSUES I JUST WANTED TO. GET A
RESPONSE ON THE TIMELINE I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- ALL RIGHT
AS I. INDICATED AT- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS THAT- A LOT OF
WHAT WE NEED TO DO NEEDS TO BE
DONE IN COLLABORATION. WITH THE
NHC AND I AM VERY THANKFUL FOR
THAT THE MEETING I HAD
YESTERDAY OUR WITH THEIR I
LEADERSHIP. OUT ON THE TIMELINE
ISSUE OUR GOAL IS- ARE ARE OUT
WE'RE WORKING ON TOGETHER.
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE LANGUAGE
GAPS IN THE POLICY TO CLOSE-
THAT I DON'T WANT TO RUSH THE
PROCESS OF COLLABORATION AS
EAGER AS WE ARE AB AT TWO THE
POLICY FROM OKAY ARE IS AT
DECEMBER TO HAVE THAT POLICY
FINALIZED. IF I CAN DO SO OUT
TOMORROW I WOULD- BUT I DO
BELIEVE WE NEED TO WORK
TOGETHER WITH OUR PARTNERS TO
CLOSE THOSE GAPS SO THAT WE'RE
ALL COMFORTABLE. WITH THE FINAL
LANGUAGE AT THE POLICY SO- HI
IF I CAN GET A SOONER DATE FOR
YOU ON THAT I WOULD I WOULD DO
SO AND WOULD NOTIFY THIS
COMMITTEE. AND IF MY TEAM IF I
HAVE THAT HAVE THAT INFORMATION
WRONG PLEASE JUST LET ME KNOW
THEY GIVE US PROVIDES
APPRECIATE THAT AND I AGREE
WITH WORKING WITHIN A H. C.
THAT NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE-
COMMITTEE YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
YOU TALKED ABOUT IT IN YOUR
TESTIMONY AND THE I'VE EVER
MENTIONED AS WELL FOR THE
CAMPUS COMMITTEES. TO BE A
REPRESENTATIVE AND HOLISTIC
AND- YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY THIS IS
AN ISSUE I JUST DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE DELAY IS
AND- AND HAVING THOSE
COMMITTEES FAILED GIVEN THAT
YOU KNOW WE HAVE A HUNDRED AND
EIGHT FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED
TRIBES AND ABOUT 20% OF ALL
THOSE TRIBES ARE IT 20% OF ALL
THOSE TRIBES ACTUALLY
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE IN THE
UNITED STATES. SO JUST WANT TO
HEAR WHAT THE UNIVERSITY'S
PERSPECTIVEON WHY THESE
COMMITTEES AND NOT HAVE THE
REQUIRED NUMBER OF MEMBERS OF
CALIFORNIA TRIBES AND JUST.
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND REALLY WHY
THIS WASN'T DONE IN THE PAST
AND I KNOW. WE'RE STILL MOVING
FORWARD BUT GIVEN THAT THE ODD
IT'S BEEN AROUND FOR AWHILE AND
THIS ISSUE HAS BEEN AROUND FOR
YEARS ALREADY. JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND FROM THE SYSTEM WIDE
APPROACH WHY THIS ISN'T DONE.
AND AT ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS
HERE YOUR QUESTIONS ARE ABOUT
ABOUT WHY THE COMMITTEES BOTH
SYSTEM WIDE IN CAMPUS
COMMITTEES ARE ARE DON'T EXIST
NOW AS FULLY CONSTITUTED AND
HAVING- EQUAL MEMBERS OF NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBES AND- AND
UNIVERSITY REPRESENTATIVES IS
THAT YOUR QUESTION I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE I'M RESPOND I'M JUST.
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
COMMITTEES ARE FULFILLED YOU
KNOW YOU'VE IDENTIFIED THAT
YOU'RE WORKING WITH ANY H. C.
I'M SAYING THERE'S YOU KNOW
HUNDRED AND EIGHT FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY THE COMMITTEES
ARE FILLED. IT ON PAGE TWENTY
SEVEN OF THE ODD REPORT IT
SHOWS AT BERKELEY HAS NO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR INSTANCE
THAT ARE MEMBERS OF ANY
FEDERALLY ARE CALIFORNIA
RECOGNIZED TRIBES IN CALIFORNIA
WHILE DAVISON UCLA DID HAVE
MEMBERS OF TRIBAL PARTICIPATION
IN SOME OF THOSE COMMITTEES.
THIS TRYING TO UNDERSTAND LIKE
YOU KNOW WE KNOW THIS IS BEEN
AN ISSUE FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
THAT'S BEEN IDENTIFIED IN THE
AUDIT- PREVIOUSLY WERE NOW WITH
THE ONE YEAR MARK. CHECK IN AND
JUST TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHY
THERE HASN'T BEEN PROGRESS
ACTUALLY FULFILL THESE
COMMITTEES AND IT SEEMS THAT
THE MOST EFFICIENT CAMPUSES
OBVIOUSLY UC BERKELEY WHO HAS
THAT NO MEMBERS ON THIS
COMMITTEE AS FAR AS- WHAT'S
REPORTED IN THE AUDIT I BELIEVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAW THAT WELL
UPDATE THAT THAT INFORMATION-
BECAUSE IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT- WHEN WE RECEIVED THE- THE
NOMINEES FROM NHC JUNE TWENTY
FOURTH. OUT OF A TWENTY TWENTY
ONE- ARE A COUPLE CAMPUS WE OUT
THE SISTER OFFICE DID ASK FOR
MORE INFORMATION FROM IN H. C.
R. IN THE IN JULY. AND WE HAVE
GOTTEN THAT INFORMATION. SO MY
UNDERSTANDING IS BERKELEY MOVED
AGGRESSIVELY TO CONSTITUTE A
COMMITTEE BUT I'LL ALLOW. THEM
TO- AT AT THE STATE THE FACTS
ON THE RECORD ON THAT AND I
KNOW DO CL A HAS AND I MIL-
THAT THE WORK IS BEING DONE TO
CONSTITUTE THE COMMITTEES NOW.
AS TO WHY THIS DIDN'T EXIST.
FOR US ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS I
DON'T KNOW HI- I AM JUST TO BE
HONEST WITH YOU ABOUT THAT- MY
FOCUS IS ON TO MOVE FORWARD HI
END TODAY I DIDN'T THE PROBLEMS
THAT WE HAVE HAD. CORRECT THEM.
AND GET US MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND I AM HAPPY- WITH
THE PARTNERSHIP THAT IT IS
DEVELOPING- WITH THE INNATE AT
THE NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE.
COMMISSION I'M HAPPY ABOUT THAT
I AM THANKFUL FOR THE HELP FROM
THE CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR ON
THIS AS WELL SO- I THINK IT
HELPS US BE AND DO BETTER AND
I'M- OUT I WISH I HAD BETTER.
FOR YOU BUT I'M HOPING THE NEXT
TIME I'M BEFORE YOU. THAT WE
WILL HAVE HAD ALL OF OUR
COMMITTEES WILL BE CONSTITUTED
ALL OF THEM PROACTIVE AND
OPERATING. ALL OF THEM MEETING
IN WAYS THAT BRING HARMONY
ACROSS ALL THE CAMPUSES IN
TERMS OF BEST PRACTICES AND
THAT YOU WILL SEE ACTIVE-
TRANSITION OF REMAIN AND ARE
MOVING TO THEIR PEOPLE AND AWAY
FROM THE UNIVERSITY. AB SO THAT
THIS CIRCLE THAT I JUST- I
REVIEWED FOR YOU IN BRIEF THAT
THAT WILL BE A FAR MORE ROBUST
STREAM. OF ACTIVITY THANK REST
PROVIDES APPRECIATE THAT I
THINK I'M JUST LOOKING FORWARD
TO- I GUESS THE DUE DILIGENCE
FROM THE SYSTEM TO NOT ONLY
HAVE PRACTICE BEST PRACTICES
LIKE YOU'VE INDICATED BUT
CONSISTENT PRACTICES ACROSS ALL
THE CAMPUSES- I THINK IT WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER WHEN YOU LOOK
AT. JUST THE AMOUNT OF
REPATRIATION OF SOME OF THE
REMAINS YOU KNOW UCLA OBVIOUSLY
AT 96% UC DAVIS THAT 89% BUT
YOU SEE THAT. ONLY BERKELEY HAS
NINETEEN PERCENT- AND THEN YOU
HEAR THAT YOU KNOW NO MEMBERS
HAVE BEEN ON. HAVE EVEN BEEN
PUT ON THE COMMITTEE FOR
BERKELEY IT'S JUST JUST WANT TO
KNOW THAT FROM- FROM THE
PROVOST FROM THE SYSTEM THAT.
THIS IS A MATTER THAT YOU GUYS
TAKE SERIOUSLY DILIGENTLY AND
I'M LOOKING FOR THAT'S WHY I
ASKED ABOUT A TIMELINE SO THAT
EVERYONE THAT'S LISTENING IN ON
TODAY'S HEARING CAN UNDERSTAND
THAT PROGRESS IS BEING MADE AND
THAT IS GOING TO BE DONE AND
NOT JUST. YOU KNOW NEXT TIME
NEXT TIME NEXT TIME AND THEN
WHEN WE CHECK IN AGREEMENTS YOU
KNOW YOU WERE WERE WERE BACK
WHERE WE WERE WE STARTED IN SO
JUST TRYING TO GET SOME
RESULTS. SOME RESOLUTION ON
SOME OF THESE ITEMS AT I. I
AGREE WITH THAT AND- I HOPE. I
HAVEN'T HAD ANYONE I'M I'M
TALKING TO MY TEAM I HAVEN'T
HAD ANYBODY UPDATE ME ON. ON
THE TIMELINE BUT LET ME JUST
SAY TO YOU. I'VE HEARD THE
COMMITTEE'S REQUEST FOR THAT.
AND LET ME WORK WITH MY TEAM TO
GET IT A MORE DETAILED RESPONSE
TO YOU. I WISH I COULD DO SO OR
ON HERE BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT I
AT THAT'S A REASONABLE REQUEST
THANK YOU THANK YOU THE
CHAIRMAN SALAS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA THANK YOU PROS BROWN
GOOD TO HAVE YOU WITH US HERE
THIS MORNING ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA AND
I WILL COMMAND MY COLLEAGUE A
MISTER SALAS FOR HIS PATIENTS
N. AND FOR IS CLARITY AND
EXPRESSING I THINK WHAT IS THE
INTENT OF THE LEGISLATURE I DO
NOT SHARE. MISTER SALAS IS
PATIENTS. I AM SITTING HERE.
SORT OF AT MY WIT'S END I DO
NOT LIKE WHAT I'M HEARING
BECAUSE ALL I'M HEARING ARE
EMPTY WORDS THE SAME EMPTY
WORDS THAT I'VE BEEN HEARING
FOR THE PAST. TWO THREE YEARS
AS CHAIR OF HIGHER EDUCATION-
TO ME THIS IS- UNACCEPTABLE I
DO NOT WANT TO HEAR CONTINUE
EXCUSES FOR WHY BERKELEY CAN'T
DO WHAT UCLA AND UC DAVIS HAVE
DONE I'M HAPPY TO HEAR THAT
OTHER CAMPUSES THAT YOU MENTION
A UC RIVERSIDE UC SANTA BARBARA
ARE DOING WELL BUT I'M REALLY
TIRED OF HEARING EXCUSES FROM
UC BERKELEY AS SOMEONE WHO HAS
A LIMITED KNOWLEDGE OF HISTORY.
EMPTY PROMISES TO THE NATIVE
AMERICAN PEOPLE IS AN
ACCEPTABLE IN THE YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WHEN THE GOVERNOR OF
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE APOLOGIES
FOR PAST ACTIONS BUT HERE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN THE FORM
OF THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO MAKE EXCUSES AS TO
WHY THINGS CAN'T GET DONE. AND
AGAIN MY COLLEAGUES- MISTER
SALAS EXPRESSED IT. VERY
COHERENTLY I AM JUST SIX
PRESSING MY COMPLETE. I DON'T
KNOW FRUSTRATION- AND JUST-
UNACCEPTABILITY OF WHAT I'M
HEARING. I DON'T WANT TO HEAR
THIS AT CONTINUED TO HEAR THE
SAME THING THAT WE'RE GOING TO
DO BETTER WE'RE GOING TO DO
BETTER AND NOTHING HAPPENS IT
YOU KNOW I WAS IN A HEARING ON
A DIFFERENT TOPIC IN HIGHER
EDUCATION AND I REMEMBER THE
PROFESSOR FROM BERKELEY WHO
SAID THINGS HAPPEN WHEN THEY
WANT TO HAPPEN I THINK THAT IS
TRUE I THINK IT'S TRUE IN LOTS
OF DIFFERENT THINGS- CERTAINLY
IN HIGHER EDUCATION I THINK
IT'S TRUE WHEN THERE'S A WILL
TO MAKE THINGS HAPPEN AND I
THINK UCLA AND UC DAVIS ARE
EXAMPLES OF THAT THEY HAPPEN
AND SO THEY KEEP COMING BACK TO
THIS LEGISLATURE TO THIS
COMMITTEE AND GIVING EXCUSES AS
TO WHY THEY HAVEN'T HAPPENED IS
UNACCEPTABLE I BELIEVE I READ
AN ARTICLE IN THE PRESS. THAT
THERE WAS SOMEONE AT UC
BERKELEY WHO DIDN'T EVEN REPORT
ALL OF THE MATERIALS THAT WERE
IN THEIR POSSESSION OR THAT
MISS REPORTED THE MATERIALS IN
THEIR POSSESSION SO I YOU KNOW
I- JUST WOULD SAY TO YOU
PROGRAMS BROWN THAT AS CHAIR OF
HIGHER EDUCATION IT'S IT SEEMS
TO ME THAT WHAT IS BERKELEY IS
DOING IS A DISMAL FAILURE. AND
TO ME AS CHAIR IT IS
UNACCEPTABLE- I AM TIRED OF
HEARING THE SAME EXCUSES. THANK
YOU OF ANY COMMENTS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA ASSEMBLY ONE
BOERNER HORVATH YES AND I'LL
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGES ON MY PATIENCE IS
LONG GONE I WENT TO UC BERKELEY
AND I TOOK MY CULTURE STUDY
RECENT REQUIREMENT BY TAKING
NATIVE AMERICAN CITIES AND
LEARNED THAT NATIVE AMERICAN
ARTIFACTS. ARE VALUABLE
CULTURAL RESOURCES THAT WOULD
NEED TO BE PROTECTED AND
RETURNED THAT WAS IN NINETEEN
NINETY THREE. THAT'S WHAT YOU
TAUGHT ME AND SO WHEN I READ
THIS REPORT IT'S BEEN YEARS TO
CORRECT THIS FIND THE WELL
THERE'S NO WAY I'M I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT MY COLLEAGUES THERE ARE
MUCH MORE POLITE THAN I AM BUT
I'M I'M NOT GONNA SPEND ANY
MORE MONEY TO DO THIS BECAUSE
YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO THIS
ALREADY YOU'RE ALREADY DOING
ANY UNIVERSITIES. SO I DON'T
LIKE TO HEAR THE EXCUSE LIKE WE
NEED MORE MONEY WE NEED MORE
COLLABORATION THAT'S ALL GREAT
BUT THERE'S NOTHING INHIBITING
YOU FROM DOING THIS BY THE
DEADLINE THAT THEY WERE
INTENDED TO BE DONE BY. SO I'M
HOPING WHEN WE NEXT YEAR IN THE
NEXT THREE MONTHS BY THE TIME
WE GET TO NOVEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. I'M GONNA GET A
REPORT ON MY DESK THIS IS THESE
PROBLEMS HAVE BEEN SOLVED AND
THIS IS HOW THEY'RE SOLVED.
BECAUSE OF LONG TIME COMING AND
IT IS ARE DUE TO OUR- OUR
TRIBAL ARM UP IN OUR OUR NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND IN THE UNITED
STATES. TO DO WHAT'S RIGHT BY
THEM THEY'VE HAD A LOT DONE
WRONG BY THEM. SO LET'S FIX IT
AND STOP MAKING EXCUSES THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY ONE
BOERNER HORVATH- AYLER
COMMITTEE COMMENTS SO FROM
BERKELEY WELL THANK YOU- MR
PROVOST AND CONTINUE TO SEE THE
FRUSTRATION OF BUILT WITHIN THE
COLLEAGUES HERE THAT WE HAVE A
LOT OF WORK TO DO AND TO CATCH
UP RIGHT AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
AND I HAVE TO BE CLEAR THAT OUT
OF THE FIVE HUNDRED. THOUSAND
NATIVE AMERICAN REMAINS
IDENTIFIED IN THE AUDIT IT WAS
A SAMPLE POLLING OF
UNIVERSITIES SO THAT'S NOT EVEN
A CLEAR PICTURE OF THE 100% OUT
THERE AND YOU SEE SO WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD TO GETTING THE
PROCESSES- MOVE FORWARD AND
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
INDIAN COMMUNITY. I THANK YOU
FOR- PRESENTING AND BEING HERE
WITH US ON THE NEXT BAKER WILL
BE MISTER RANDY KATZ VICE
CHANCELLOR FOR RESEARCH AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY. THANK YOU- TERRAIN
MOST- AND CHAIRS SALAS MEMBERS
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY
SELECT COMMITTEE ON NATIVE
AMERICAN AFFAIRS AND OF COURSE
THE TRIBAL REPRESENTATIVES
RESPECTED GUESTS I WANT TO WISH
YOU A GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
RANDY HOWARD KATZ AND THE
CHANCELLOR'S THE BERKELEY
CHANCELLOR'S CAMPUS DESIGNATE
FOR NECRO IN MY ROLE AS VICE
CHANCELLOR FOR RESEARCH THE
FIRST MUSEUM OF ANTHROPOLOGY
WHICH HOLDS THE NATIVE AMERICAN
ANCESTORS AND ARTIFACTS UNDER
OUR CARE REPORTS TO ME BOB
STOPS WITH ME I THINK KNOWLEDGE
THAT MY CAMPUS IT'S ON THE
TERRITORY OF THE WHO THE
ANCESTRAL AND UNCEDED LANDS OF
THE CHURCH ANNUAL ALONE ANCHOR
THE SUCCESSORS OF THE HISTORIC
AND SOVEREIGN BAND OF ALAMEDA
COUNTY WE AFFIRM INDIGENOUS
SOVEREIGNTY AND ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT BERKELEY THE COUNCIL VOTE
TO AMERICAN INDIAN AND
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE I THINK
KNOWLEDGE THAT OUR CAMPUS HAS
NOT ACHIEVED THE TIMELY
REPATRIATION OF NATIVE AMERICAN
ANCESTORS AND BELONGINGS IN THE
PAST WE ARE COMMITTED TO DOING
BETTER IN THE FUTURE. AND I
BELIEVE WE ARE DOING BETTER I
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT THE
AUDIT WAS PERFORMED IN TWENTY
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS IN THE
LAST TWO YEARS AND I HOPE TO
ADDRESS THE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS THAT HAVE ARISEN IN
THIS TESTIMONY TO THIS POINT
OVER THE PART OF THE LAST THREE
YEARS WE HAVE MADE SYSTEM
SYSTEMIC CHANGES TO OUR
PRACTICES REGARDING KANNST
CONSULTATION AND REPATRIATION
AND ARE HEARING TO ALL NAC PROP
CALLUM THAT PRO. AND UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA POLICY I AM
PERSONALLY COMMITTED TO WORKING
CLOSELY WITH TRACK WITH THE
TRIBAL COMMUNITY TO DEVELOP
MORE PRODUCTIVE RELATIONSHIPS
AND ENGAGE COLLABORATIVELY. IN
THE DECISION MAKING AS EVIDENCE
OF OUR NEW PRACTICES AND
COMMITMENT ARE INACCURATE VICE
RE COMMITTEE HAS BEEN
RECONSTITUTED IN COMPLIANCE
WITH U. C. O. P. POLICY
EFFECTIVE JULY FIRST. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. I AND THIS WAS DONE
UNDER THE DIRECTION OF THE
NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE
COMMISSION WE ARE NOW
SCHEDULING MEETINGS WITH THE
CURRENT ACADEMIC YEAR THE NEW
COMMITTEE WILL BE RESPONSIBLE.
FOR DRAFTING OUR REPATRIATION
STRATEGIC PLAN I HAVE INCREASED
OUR OUTREACH AND COMMUNICATION
WITH TRIED. TO THE WORK OF OUR
RECENTLY APPOINTED NARAL PRO
LIAISON A POSITION FORMED ONLY
FIFTEEN MONTHS AGO. WE HAVE
ENGAGE WITH OVER ONE HUNDRED
TRIBAL ENTITIES THESE GROUPS
HAVE AN INTEREST IN THE
MAJORITY OF THE ANCESTORS AND
ARTIFACTS UNDER OUR CARE SINCE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY MODIFIED OUR
CONSULTATIONPRACTICES IN OUR
DELIBERATIONS NOW PRIVILEGE
TRIBAL KNOWLEDGE AND EXPERTISE
IN ANY DECISIONS THAT WE
UNDERTAKE. WE ONLY REQUIRE
SUFFICIENT SUBMISSION TO
ESTABLISH A PREPONDERANCE OF
EVIDENCE AS EVIDENCE OF
PROGRESS AND IT'S VERY FIRST
MEETING IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN ARE
RECONSTITUTED KNACK PRESS
VAISAKHI COMMITTEE APPROVED A
CLAIM IN TEN MINUTES THAT HAD
BEEN IN PROCESS. FOR FOURTEEN
YEARS DUE TO CONTINUING REQUEST
FOR ADDITIONAL EVIDENCE WE HAVE
A NEW PROCESS A MORE AGILE
PROCESS IN A STRONG COMMITMENT
TO REPATRIATION AND
COLLABORATION WITH THE NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY WE NO LONGER
DELAY DISPOSITIONS WHILE WE
WAIT FOR ALL CONSULTED TRIES TO
RESPOND. INSTEAD WE CONSULT
WITH TRIBES TO DEFINE A
REASONABLE CONTACT IN WAITING
PERIOD THIS ALLOWS US TO
ACCELERATE THE TRANSFER OF
CUSTODY WHILE RESPECTING THE
INTERESTS OF THE CONSULTANT
PRICE NO I KNOWLEDGE THAT THERE
ARE ITEMS IN OUR INVENTORY THAT
ARE MISSING. THIS BRINGS GREAT
DISPLAYS THERE AND SUFFERING TO
ME. IT IT ON BEHALF OF THE
EFFECT THAT I KNOW THAT THIS
HAS ON THE NATIVE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY. WE NOW LIST ALL
KNOWN MISSING ITEMS AND ARE
ACTIVELY CONSULTING WITH TRIBES
TO CONDUCT FURTHER SEARCHES
WITH THEIR PERMISSION SO AS NOT
TO CAUSE HARM OR DAMAGE TO
ANCESTORS AND BELONGINGS. UNDER
OUR CARE IN KEEPING WITH THE
INTERIM POLICY WE CONDUCTED
OUTREACH TO THE CAMPUS
COMMUNITY TO ENSURE THAT NO
NATIVE AMERICAN ANCESTORS ARE
HELD OUTSIDE THE HEARST MUSEUM
THIS PROCESS IDENTIFIED A SET
OF REMAINS THAT WERE
INAPPROPRIATELY HAVE ONE OF OUR
OTHER MUSEUMS. WE RESPONDED
IMMEDIATELY AND ENSURE THAT THE
IDENTIFIED REMAINS WERE
RETURNED TO THE AFFILIATED
TRIBES I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
THE POLICY WORKED AS IT WAS
INTENDED TO WORK BY
COMMUNICATING TO OUR CAMPUS WE
IDENTIFIED. ITEMS THAT WERE
MISSED HELPED AND SO WE WERE
ABLE TO REACT QUICKLY TO ENSURE
THAT THEY WERE UNDER PROPER
CARE AND ACCELERATED THE
REPATRIATION AND RETURN OF
THOSE ANCESTORS TO THE
APPROPRIATE TRIBAL COMMUNITIES
LOOK I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO TO
ACHIEVE FULL REPATRIATION OF
ANCESTORS AND BELONGINGS THE
FACT OF THE MATTER IS 95% OF
UC'S HOLDINGS IN THIS REGARD
ARE LOCATED AT BERKELEY OUR
CULTURE OUR HOLDINGS ARE MUCH
MUCH LARGER. THAN UCLA DAVIS OR
THE OTHER UC CAMPUSES WE HAVE A
WE HAVE A HEAVY LIFT CENTAGE IS
DON'T REALLY CAPTURE THE
NUMBERS IN TERMS OF NUMBER OF-
ANCESTRAL REMAINS AND FUNERARY
OBJECTS AND OTHER CULTURAL
ITEMS THAT ARE IN THE BERKELEY
COLLECTION COMPARED TO THE REST
OF THE UC SYSTEM. WE ARE
COMMITTED. TO WORK WITH OUR
CAMPUS AND WITH THE OFFICE OF
THE PRESIDENT AND OTHERS TO
SECURE THE NECESSARY STAFFING
AND FUNDING. TO ACCELERATE THE
PROGRESS THAT WE HAVE BEGUN IN
WHICH WE ARE COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING IN THE FUTURE. I
LOOK FORWARD TO BUILDING AND IN
FRANK. REGARD REBUILDING TRUST
BETWEEN OUR CAMPUS THE TRIBES
WHOSE ANCESTORS ARE IN OUR CARE
AND OF COURSE WITH YOU THE
STATE LEGISLATURE THANK YOU AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO THEIR. ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS YES RENAISSANCE THANK
YOU RESTAURANTS SAID JUST QUICK
QUESTION AND I APPRECIATE YOU
MAKE A COMMENT ABOUT THE
PERCENTAGES BUT STILL DOESN'T
EXPLAIN YOU KNOW WHY THAT'S WHY
IT'S TAKEN SO LONG FOR THE
COMMITTEES AND I BELIEVE IN THE
AUDIENCE ALLUDED TO THE FACT
THAT FOR THINKIN SEE IF I CAN-FIND IT IN THE ADDED I WANT TO
QUOTE IT CORRECTLY I CAN'T SEEM
TO FIND IT HERE BUT BASICALLY
THE AUDITOR'S CONCLUSION.
ALLUDES TO THAT ALLUDES OR COME
TO THE CONCLUSION THAT
BERKELEY'S APPROACH YOU KNOW
UNNECESSARY LIFE UNNECESSARILY
PROLONGS THE PROCESS OF
REPATRIATING REMAINS AND I
BELIEVE THE AUDIT REPORTED YOU
KNOW UC BERKELEY- YOU KNOW
CENTERS INITIAL LETTER OUT TO
SOME OF THE TRIBES THEY DID
HEAR FROM MANY YOU KNOW THEY
THEY THEY CLAIM AND YOU CAN
TELL ME BECAUSE YOU'RE A
BERKELEY HERE THE COP THAT THE
CAMPUS IS NOT CONNECT FOR THE
WORK ON A. BECAUSE QUOTE IT IS
NOT THE CAMPUS PLACE PRESSURE
TRIBES RESPOND TO THE TIMELINE
THAT IT SETS AND QUOTE. AS A
RESULT OF TOOK ANOTHER TWENTY
MONTHS UNTIL THE EVENTUAL
RETURN OF THE REMAINS. AB THE
TRIBE WAS CLAIMING SO TOOK
ANOTHER SO TOOK MORE THAN THREE
YEARS FOR THIS PROCESS IN WHICH
I SEE NO OTHER TRIBE DISPUTED.
WHO SHOULD RIVER WHO SHOULD
RECEIVE THE REMAINS- SO I GUESS
THE QUESTION IS YOU KNOW WHAT
IS UC BERKELEY GOING TO DO TO
PREVENT A RECURRENCE AND ENSURE
MORE TIMELY PROCESS. UP TO
THREE YEARS TO. REPATRIATE
THESE REMAINS- YOU SAID YOU
YOU'VE IMPLEMENTED A NEW POLICY
DOES THAT MEAN WHAT'S THE TIME
LINE LOOK FOR TRIBES THAT ARE
LOOKING AT RECLAIMING- REMAINS.
YES THANK YOU FOR THANK YOU FOR
YOUR YOUR QUESTIONS YES THE
HOMELESS- AGAIN I IN MY
TESTIMONY I MENTIONED- THAT OUR
COMMITTEE WAS ABLE TO RENDER A
DECISION IN TEN MINUTES
COMPARED TO MANY MANY MONTHS
PREVIOUSLY AND I THINK THAT'S
INDICATIVE OF OUR REVISED WHAT
I SHOULD SAY IS PROCESS AS
OPPOSED TO POLICY- THERE ARE
SEVERAL STEPS AFFECTED STEPS
THAT WE'VE TAKEN IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS INCLUDING THE
APPOINTMENT. OF A FULL TIME
CNAC PROCREATE SON WHO WORKS
PROACTIVELY WITH THE NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY TO IDENTIFY
ITEMS IN OUR COLLECTION OF
INTEREST TO THEM AND CAN ASSIST
THEM IN PREPARING THE SORT OF
NECESSARY- SORT OF- PAPERWORK
IF YOU WOULD TO- GO THROUGH THE
SORT OF FEDERALLY MANDATED
PROCESS SEES FOR RETURNING-
ITEMS- THAT ARE ASSOCIATED WITH
IT WE NO LONGER- PLAY THE
WAITING GAME- GIVE US MORE
EVIDENCE GIVE US MORE EVIDENCE
GIVES MORE EVIDENCE EACH ONE OF
THESE INTERACTIONS TAKING
LITERALLY MONTHS IF NOT YEARS
TO COMPLETE A CYCLE. WE'VE NOW
MOVED TOWARDS- TAKING A MUCH
GREATER WEIGHT OF ORAL
TESTIMONY AND- WE'RE NOT
LOOKING FOR- ARCHAEOLOGICAL-
PROOF- AFFILIATION BUT WE'RE
WE'RE FOLLOWING- THE NEW
PROCESS- LISTENING TO ORAL
TRADITIONS AND TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT GEOGRAPHIC LOCATION AND
THINGS OF THAT NATURE. WHICH
WILL WILL HELP US IN A MUCH
MORE RAPID APPROACH- IN ORDER
TO RENDER A DECISION TO-
REPATRIATES SO THERE ARE
NUMEROUS THINGS BOTH IN TERMS
OF ADDITIONAL STAFFING IN
ADDITIONAL STAFF ROLES. TO WORK
PROACTIVELY AND COLLABORATIVELY
WITH THE NATIVE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY AND AN INTERNAL
PROCESS THAT- YOU KNOW VALUES
AND PRIVILEGES THE ORAL
HISTORIES AND TRADITIONS SO
THAT WE CAN GET TO A
REPATRIATION DECISION MUCH
FASTER. THESE ARE EXAMPLES- OF
I THINK- THESE KINDS OF
APPROACHES HAVE BEEN USED AT
OTHER UC CAMPUSES AND IS A PART
OF THE VALUE OF THE SYSTEM WIDE
APPROACH. THAT YOU SEE AS THAT
WE CAN LEARN BEST PRACTICES
FROM THOSE CAMPUSES THAT HAVE
DONE WELL IN LARGELY IF NOT
COMPLETELY REPATRIATING THEIR
HOLDINGS SUCH AS UCLA AND
DAVIS- WERE WERE ADOPTING THEIR
BEST PRACTICES SO THAT WE CAN
MOVE THROUGH WHAT AMOUNTS TO
THE LARGEST COLLECTION. OF
HOLDINGS WITHIN THE UC SYSTEM.
IN A MUCH MORE RAPID MANNER
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT
AND- LOOK FORWARD TO MORE.
EXPEDIENCY AND THAT WITH THE-
WITH THE NEW- POLICIES- JUST
QUICK FOLLOW UP QUESTION YOU
MENTIONED EARLIER THE UC
BERKELEY- CONTAINS A LARGE
INVENTORY AND- THINK IT WAS
REPORTED THAT OVER HALF A
MILLION TRIBAL ARTIFACTS ARE
ACTUALLY IN UC BERKELEY'S
POSSESSION- AND I KNOW YOU
SAID. YOU KNOW PERCENTAGES.
DON'T DO- DON'T TELL THE WHOLE
STORY BUT CAN YOU TELL ME OF.
THOSE TRIBAL REMAINS AND
ARTIFACTS HOW MANY HAVE BEEN
REPATRIATED OF THE NEARLY HALF
A MILLION YES WELL I WILL GET
YOU YOU KNOW SORT OF FULL
INFORMATION IN A FOLLOW UP ON
THAT BUT I DO HAVE SOME
STATISTICS AT MY FINGERTIPS OF
WHAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS JUST TO
PUT THINGS IN IN PERSPECTIVE.
SO WE OVER THE PAST YEAR WE
REPATRIATED TWO HUNDRED AND
NINETY EIGHT CENTS OF ANCESTRAL
REMAINS- IF I RECALL THE RIGHT
NUMBER WE HAVE ABOUT TEN
THOUSAND- WE HAD OF
REPATRIATION A FEW YEARS AGO A
FIFTEEN HUNDRED REMAINS- SO TWO
HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT OVER YEAR
DOESN'T SOUND LIKE A LOT BUT
IT'S INDICATIVE OF. OUR EFFORTS
TO ACCELERATE THE RETURN- OVER
ALMOST SIXTEEN THOUSAND SETS OF
FUNERARY OBJECTS WERE RETURNED
IN THE LAST TWELVE MONTHS AND
TWENTY THREE CULTURAL ITEMS WE
HAD SEVEN NOTICES OF A
REPATRIATION OVER THE LAST
TWELVE MONTHS AND I LEARNED
THIS MORNING WE HAD AN EIGHT
THAT WAS PUBLISHED YESTERDAY SO
THESE ARE SIGNATURES OF HOW
WE'RE TRYING TO ACCELERATE. BUT
CHAIR CHAIR SALAS I ALSO WANT
TO PUT IN THE IN THE
PERSPECTIVE OKAY TEN THOUSAND
UMAN REMAINS WE WISH TO
REPATRIATE ALL OF THEM. ARE IN
THE LAST YEAR WE'VE DONE ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED YOU CAN DO THE
MATH THIS IS JUST AN ENORMOUS
LEFT IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY TO WHOM THESE REMAINS
ARE- AFFILIATED WITH THE LONG
TWO OR THE APPROPRIATE
DESCENDANTS- WE DON'T WANT TO
STAND IN THE WAY OF THAT BUT
JUST THE SHEER NUMBERS
REPRESENT A TREMENDOUS
CHALLENGE FOR US WITH OUR
EXISTING RESOURCES. TO GET FROM
THREE HUNDRED A YEAR TO A
NUMBER MORE LIKE. THREE
THOUSAND A YEAR. WHICH IS WHERE
WE WANT TO GO AND JUST AS
FOLLOW UP WHAT WOULD YOU NEED
TO ACCOMPLISH THAT I MEAN. I
WOULD IMAGINE DNA TESTING HELPS
A LOT SHE SAID USE A DIFFERENT
METHODS TERRITORIAL. AND WHAT
NOT BUT WHAT. WHAT WOULD IT
TAKE TO GET THERE TO THE THREE
THOUSAND METER YES WELL THE AYE
AYE AGAIN AN EXCELLENT QUESTION
SHARE SALAS- DNA TESTING IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE USE OUR
BECAUSE IT'S IN THE DESTRUCTIVE
MATH METHOD AND YOU KNOW THERE
ARE MANY MANY CULTURAL ISSUES
ASSOCIATED WITH- USING THAT
KIND OF APPROACH SO THE WAY
THAT WE ARE GOING FORWARD IS
THAT MANY OF THE ANCESTRAL
REMAINS A LARGE VERY LARGE
NUMBER OF THEM. I AS ONE COULD
IMAGINE WERE FROM THE
GEOGRAPHIC AREA OF THE UP ALONE
EIGHT PEOPLE AND- THE SORT OF
BAY AREA COMMUNITIES AND SO BY
WORKING WITH THAT GROUP OF-
TRIBAL COMMUNITIES WE ARE HAVE
THE POSSIBILITY OF BEING ABLE
TO REPATRIATE VERY LARGE
NUMBERS. OF REMAINS IN A SINGLE
ACTION IN A SINGLE INTERACTION
WITH THE TRIBES AND THROUGH THE
NECESSARY THE DICTATED BY
POLICY PROCESS SEEMS TO DO IT
SO THAT'S THE APPROACH THAT
WE'RE TAKING IS TO IDENTIFY
THOSE ITEMS AND ANCESTORS
WITHIN OUR COLLECTION. THAT WE
ALREADY KNOW BECAUSE OF THE
GEOGRAPHY THE COMMUNITY OF
INTEREST ARE SO THAT WE CAN
WORK WITH THEM TO ACHIEVE LARGE
GROUP REPATRIATIONS.
SIMULTANEOUSLY AND THAT'S OW
WE'LL BE ABLE TO GET TO THE
VERY LARGE NUMBERS AND OF
COURSE IN ORDER TO DO THAT WE
NEED. THE RIGHT AMOUNT OF- YOU
KNOW SORT OF STAFFING SUPPORT-
IN ORDER TO DOCUMENT THOSE
THINGS AND SO ON AND I I'D
MENTION THAT NOT BECAUSE I WANT
TO SLOW THE PROCESS DOWN. WE
ARE ENTIRELY COMMITTED TO
REPATRIATING OUR ENTIRE
COLLECTION AS SOON AS IS
FEASIBLE IT'S REALLY A QUESTION
OF GETTING THOSE INVENTORIES
CORRECT CORRECT IDENTIFYING THE
COMMUNITIES TO INTERACT WITH
WORKING WITH THOSE COMMUNITIES
TO ESTABLISH THE RIGHT
DOCUMENTATION SO THAT WE CAN DO
VERY LARGE GROUP REPATRIATIONS-
OF. ALL IN THE SINGLES WOULD
GOT IT UNDERSTOOD APPRECIATE
THAT AND YOU KNOW WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THE REPORT A LOT OF
IT. POINTS TO INADEQUACIES AT
UC BERKELEY. AND OTHERS ASKING
THE SAME QUESTION LAST
PROPOSES- WHEN YOU ANTICIPATE.
I GUESS JUST FOR UC BERKELEY
ANYWAYS IMPLEMENTING ALL OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE AUDIT
REPORT YEAH SO- AS I MENTIONED
TO OUR- WE HAVE ALREADY
RECONSTITUTE ARE NAG ADVISORY
COMMITTEE EFFECTIVE JULY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SO WE'RE ONE
OF THE TWO UC CAMPUSES THAT
THAT ACTED ON THE COMMITTEE.
RECOMMENDED THAT THE- AUDIT
FINDING ABOUT ESTABLISHING-
COMMITTEE WITH TRIBAL
REPRESENTATION WE'VE GOT THAT
SINCE JULY FIRST OF THIS YEAR
WE'RE READY TO- COURSE
SCHEDULING- THE SET OF MEETINGS
FOR THE COMING- ACADEMIC HERE%
TO REVIEW CASES AND TO MAKE
REPATRIATION DECISIONS SO WE'RE
WELL ADVANCED IN THAT. IN TERMS
OF THE ISSUE WITH RESPECT TO OF
LOST ITEMS- WE HAVE IMPROVED
OUR INVENTORY WE- HAVE IN MAKE
SURE THAT IT IT KEEPS TRACK OF
ALL LOST KNOWN ITEMS- AND WE
ARE IN CONSULTATION WITH TRIBES
ON HOW TO IDENTIFY THOSE SO WE
HAVE A PROCESS IN PLACE FOR
DEALING WITH THAT
RECOMMENDATION. AND THEN- THE
THIRD RECOMMENDATION WAS TO
MODIFY OUR PROCESSES TO- THAT
WHILE BERKELEY WAS HELD OUT AS
AS HOLDING AS OUR STANDARD AN
EXCESSIVE DEMAND FOR EVIDENCE
BEFORE MAKING IT A REPATRIATION
DECISION AS I MENTIONED WE NOW
AWAIT VERY HEAVILY- TRIBAL
KNOWLEDGE- ORAL TRADITION
GEOGRAPHIC LOCATION AND WE DO
NOT WISH TO OVER BURDEN. THE
NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITY WITH
WITH HIGH LEVEL OF DOCUMENTS
WRITTEN- SCIENTIFICALLY
COLLECTED THE AND VALIDATED
EVIDENCE IN ORDER TO DRIVE OUR
REPATRIATION PROCESSES SO I
THINK WE'RE WELL ON OUR WAY TO
MAKING PROGRESS ON ALL OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE AUDIT.
RIGHT THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
THE PROGRESS THAT STILL DIDN'T
HEAR TIMELINE ON THAT BUT. DO
YOU IT HERE'S AND ALLOW I KNOW
FOR THE ARTIFACTS IS GOING TO
TAKE A LONG TIME BUT- FOR SOME
OF THE THINGS LISTED ON THE
AUDIT OBVIOUSLY SAID JULY FIRST
YOU HAD SOME OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS A LISTENING USE THAT
COMMITTEE IS. FAILED YES SO
OKAY THANK YOU AND I'M JUST SO
TIMELINE WISE YOU'VE MET SOME
OF THESE RECOMMENDATIONS
ALREADY YOU SEE YOURSELF FOR
FAILING ALL OF ALL OF THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND WHAT GIVEN
TIMELINE AGAIN I'M SORRY YES
SO- AS I MENTIONED THE
COMMITTEE WAS WAS CONSTITUTED
IN AN EMPANELLED IN THE FORM OF
THE- POLICY RECOMMENDATION WITH
CONSULTATION WITH A NATIVE
AMERICAN ITAGE
EFFECTIVE JULY FOR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SO THAT ONE. WE GOT
A WE HAVE NOTIFIED OUR
INVENTORIES TO RECORD ALL OF
THE LOST ITEMS THAT WE KNOW- I
THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN COLLECTED
AND I MENTIONED THAT WE REVISED
OUR- PROCESS FOR- YOU KNOW-
WAITING AND LISTENING TO
EVIDENCE FROM THE TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES AND THIS WILL NOW
GO INTO EFFECT IN THE IN THE
MEETINGS THAT WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF SCHEDULING TO REVIEW
REPATRIATION REQUEST. OVER THE-
YOU KNOW OVER THE NEXT ACADEMIC
YEAR SO I CAN CONFIDENTLY STATE
THAT ALL OF THE AUDIT-
RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE BEEN
ACHIEVED THANK YOU APPRECIAT
THAT- JUST ONE FINAL QUESTION
IF I MAY MISTER CHAIR- IS THERE
ANYTHING THAT YOU NEED FROM THE
LET'S JUST SAY IT LEGISLATURE
SIDE FROM RESOURCES TO KIND OF
MOVE UP TO. THE GOAL OF THREE
THOUSAND ANCESTRAL REMAINS
BEING REPATRIATED EVERY YEAR.
IS THERE ANYTHING POLICY WISE
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE EITHER-
AT- YOU COP WITH THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA'S OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT THAT TO HELP YOU
IMPLEMENT WHAT YOU NEED TO DO
IT. AT BERKELEY OR IS THERE ANY
FURTHER AUTHORIZATION YOU NEED
FROM THE LEGISLATURE BUT AGAIN
AN EXCELLENT QUESTION YOU KNOW
I REALLY THINK THAT- YOU
GETTING OUR INTERIM POLICY TO
BECOME THE POLICY WILL BE
EXTREMELY HELPFUL- LEADERSHIP
FROM THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN VERY
EFFECTIVE IN TERMS OF. REALLY
SHARING BEST PRACTICES ACROSS
THE SYSTEM- YOU KNOW I THINK
WHAT THE LEGISLATOR HAS DONE IS
BASICALLY- YOU KNOW PRODDED US
INTO ACTION AND- I REALLY- HELP
THE UNIVERSITY RE ORIENT HIS
THINKING TOWARDS OUR
OVERARCHING GOAL IS TO
REPATRIATE AS FAST AS POSSIBLE.
TO DO THAT WE NEED THE
RESOURCES AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT'S NOT REALLY WHAT YOU'RE
ASKING ABOUT BUT I THINK- YOU
KNOW WITH ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
WE CAN ACHIEVE THE GOAL OF. A
MY PERSONAL GOAL IS TO
REPATRIATE THOSE ANCESTRAL
REMAINS WITHIN THE NEXT DECADE
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT AND YEAH I KNOW
RESOURCE IS ALWAYS AN ISSUE BUT
YOU KNOW I BELIEVE SINCE I'VE
BEEN HERE WE'VE INCREASED THE
AMOUNT OF BUDGETARY EVERY TIME
WE TALK ABOUT THE BUDGET I
KNOW- THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S RECEIVED-
ADDITIONAL FUNDING AND WE'VE
ALWAYS FOUGHT FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR HIGHER EDUCATION
SO. I DON'T KNOW IF THAT MEANS
WE NEED TO LINE ITEM SOME OF
THOSE BUDGET. AUGMENTATIONS TO
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA TO
HELP YOU MEET THESE GOALS- BUT
I GUESS T'S A FURTHER
DISCUSSION WHEN WE GET BACK
INTO OUR BUDGET COMMITTEES
THANK YOU THANK YOU- CLOSE
COMMENT SOME ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I HAVE SOME FOLLOW UP
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS ON THIS
THE REPATRIATION PROCESS TO THE
NAY AMERICAN PEOPLE IS NOTHING
NEW THIS IS SOMETHING THAT HAS
GONE ON SINCE- THE CREATION OF
THE UC SYSTEM STARTING WITH-
THE PERSON OF IT IS A
CALIFORNIA NINETY SHE- SO IT'S
NOT A NEW TOPIC AND FEELING THE
FRUSTRATION OF SOME OF THE
MEMBERS IT DID CHIME IN WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT- THE ORAL HISTORY-
IT TOOK A PIECE OF LEGISLATION
AB TWO SEVENTY FIVE TO
IMPLEMENT. AND TO BASICALLY-
FORCE THAT ORAL TRADITION TO BE
ACCEPTED WITHIN THE UC SYSTEM'S
A MUSEUMS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. SO MY QUESTION-
IS BY INCLUDING THAT ORAL
HISTORY AND NOW UNDERSTANDING
THAT MANY OF THE TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES RETAIN THAT
HISTORICAL KNOWLEDGE THE ORAL
TRADITIONS THAT HAVE GREATER
WEIGHT AS FAR AS UNDERSTANDING
THE CULTURAL IDENTITIES AND THE
CULTURAL REMAINS THAT REMAIN IN
YOUR ARCHIVES HAS THAT-
EXPEDITE THE PROCESS BY.
ENSURING THAT THE VOICE OF
ELDERS AND HISTORICAL KNOWLEDGE
IS PART OF THE PROCESS. AGAIN
CHAIR RAMOSE A VERY EXCELLENT
EXCELLENT QUESTION AND ONE THAT
HAS IT HAS REALLY IS AT THE
HEART OF HOW. WE I THINK I'M
SPEAKING FOR THE WHOLE UC
SYSTEM HAVE DEEPLY RETHOUGHT
AND RECONSIDERED OUR
REPATRIATION. OF PROCESS THE
DECISION PROCESS- IN THE PAST
IN THE IN NOT WHAT I WOULDHOPE
TO CHARACTERIZE AS DISTANT
PAST- IT BUT IN THE PAST- THE
SORT OF PROCESS WAS SET UP SO
AS TO- PLACE HIGH VALUE ON
RETAINING THESE ITEMS FOR
SCIENTIFIC X. EXAMINATION AND
RESEARCH. THIS IS NOT WHERE WE
ARE TODAY OUR OVER ARCHING GOAL
AND DESIRE IS TO REPATRIATE
WERE POISED TO REPATRIATE WE
WANT TO REPATRIATE WE WANT TO
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE WITH
THE UNIVERSITY WITH THE NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY TO
REPATRIATE AS QUICKLY AND AS
EXPEDITIOUSLY AS POSSIBLE. AS
PART OF THAT A PROCESS WHICH
REQUIRES JYJ AMOUNTS OF WRITTEN
DOCUMENTATION SO SCIENTIFICALLY
EVALUATED AND SO ON- IS A
BURDEN TO THE NATIVE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY AND LEADS TO- I THINK
STAND THE TIMELINE AND DELAY
ASSOCIATED WITH NEW ABLE TO
BOTH COLLECT THE INFORMATION
AND THEN ACT UPON IT. ORAL YOU
THE USE. OF ORAL TRADITION WE
CAN WE CAN ENGAGE IN A CALL
WITH- A NATIVE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY AND LISTEN TO THEIR
ELDERS RECITE. THE ORAL
TRADITION OF THE- YOU KNOW THE
LAND- AND WHICH THESE THESE
PARTICULAR ANCESTRY REMAINS-
NAY HAVE BEEN FOUND AS BEING
PART OF THE TRADITIONAL LANDS-
FIVE PARTICULAR NATIVE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY AND SO ON. WE DON'T
REQUIRE THE SAME LEVEL OF
DETAILED DOCUMENTATION AND SO
ON SO WE ARE PRIVILEGING WE ARE
WAITING IN OUR DECISIONS THE
TRIBAL KNOWLEDGE ORAL
TRADITIONS AND SO ON WHEN WE'RE
DOING OUR DELIBERATIONS ABOUT
REPATRIATION AN AFFILIATION.
AND WE ARE ARE REALLY SETTING
AS OUR PRIORITY THAT WE WANT TO
REPATRIATE OUR PRIORITY IS TO
REPATRIATE NOT TO RETAIN. THESE
ANCESTRAL REMAINS AND ITEMS FOR
SCIENTIFIC STUDY THAT IS NO
LONGER THE DESIRED GOAL OF THE
UNIVERSITY TO HAVE THESE ITEMS
UNDER ITS CARE OUR GOAL IS TO
IDENTIFY THE AFFILIATED
COMMUNITIES AND REPATRIATE. TO
THOSE COMMUNITIES TO ASSIST IN
ANY WAY WE CAN TO HAVE AS AS
CLEAR AND TRANSPARENT PROCESS
SEES AS AS I CHILD PROCESSES SO
THAT WE CAN MAKE THAT HAPPEN
AND- THE ABILITY TO WAIT ORAL
TRADITIONS. IS A DRAMATIC
REDUCTION ON THE BURDEN TO THE
NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITIES TO
THE FACT THAT SO IT IS A WAY TO
ACHIEVE THAT GOAL OF RAPID.
AGILE REPATRIATION THANK YOU
THANK YOU- FOR YOUR COMMENTS I
HAVE A FEW MORE QUESTIONS YOU
KEPT MENTIONING- IN YOUR
TESTIMONY LOST ITEMS CAN YOU
ELABORATE ON THE LOST ITEMS-
MEANING. THERE'S A LOST ITEMS-
REMAINS OF ANCESTORS OF
CALIFORNIAN TRIBES THAT HAVE
GONE MISSING. YES- YOU KNOW
AGAIN- THIS IS THIS ISN'T AN
ADMITTEDLY AN EMBARRASSMENT.
FOR THE UNIVERSITY AND FOR ME
PERSONALLY THAT THERE WERE
ANCESTRAL REMAINS THAT- WE KNEW
WERE IN OUR CARE. BUT WERE NOT
WITHIN OUR MUSEUM SO THE
QUESTION IS WHERE ARE THEY IN
THIS IS DEEPLY TROUBLING DEEPLY
TROUBLING- TO NOT HAVE AS
ACCURATE 21100% ACCURATE
INVENTORIES- THIS IS
REQUIREMENTS WE MUST HAVE THIS.
NOW I HAVE TO ADMIT AS PART OF
THE PROCESS AS PART OF THE NEW
POLICIES THE INTERIM POLICY WE
COMMUNICATED TO OUR CAMPUS
COMMUNITY- THE WORD WENT OUT
THAT ALL ITEMS. OF THIS NATURE
MUST BE UNDER THE CONTROL OF
THE HEARST MUSEUM OF
ANTHROPOLOGY ON OUR CAMPUS AND
THIS WAS BROADLY COMMUNICATED
AS PART OF THE NEW THE NEW
SYSTEM ON POLICY. IN THE RESULT
OF THAT IS THIS COMMUNICATION
METHOD WORKED WE WERE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY- SOME ANCESTRAL
REMAINS THAT WERE NOT IN THE
MUSEUM WE WERE ABLE TO COLLECT
THEM RETURN THEM TO THE MUSEUM
AND ULTIMATELY RETURN THEM TO
THE APPROPRIATE- DESCENDING
COMMUNITY. BUT NEVERTHELESS
THOSE ITEMS WERE NOT IN THE
MUSEUM- AND SO- YOU KNOW THIS
AGAIN AS I SAID BEFORE IS
DEEPLY TROUBLING TROUBLING
WE'VE UPDATED OUR INVENTORIES
WE NOW HAVE A MUCH BETTER
KNOWLEDGE OF WHAT WE BELIEVE IS
UNDER OUR CARE BUT WE DO NOT
KNOW WHERE THOSE ITEMS ARE- MY
STAFF IT'S- YEAH THEY'RE
HELPING ME OUT HERE. IT'S ABOUT
ONE HALF OF 1% OF THE ITEMS-
THAT FALL INTO THIS CATEGORY SO
IT'S A SMALL NUMBER. BUT IT'S
ONE THAT WE ARE PREPARED TO
TRACK DOWN IN IMPROVE OUR
INVENTORIES BUT WE DO THIS IN
CLOSE CONSULTATION WITH A
NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE- SOMETIMES YOU CAN DO
MORE HARM. BY LOOKING FOR
THINGS THEN THEN NOT
NECESSARILY KNOWING EXACTLY
WHERE THEY ARE I KNOW THAT
SOUNDS SOUNDS A LITTLE STRANGE
BUT- WE DO NOT WISH TO DISTURB.
THE ANCESTRAL REMAINS THAT WE
HAVE IN ORDER TO FIND IT MAY BE
ON A MISSING ANCESTRAL BONE. OR
SOME SUCH- YOU KNOW SOME ARE
PART OF AN ANCESTRAL REMAINS-
SO WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE ADVANCING
NOT TO SLOW ANYTHING DOWN IN
NOT TO- YOU KNOW SORT OF MAKING
EXCUSES BUT IN IN. VERY
CULTURALLY SENSITIVE WAY OF
WORKING WITH THE NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY TO CORRECT
AND UPDATE OUR INVENTORY TO GET
TO ONE HUNDRED PERCENT. BUT IN
A WAY THAT DOES NOT DO MORE
HARM THAN GOOD- AS WE GO
FORWARD THANK YOU- FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND REGARD ONE OF
THOSE WHAT REMAINS REPRESENTS A
PERSON REPRESENTS FAMILIES AND
IN MANY CASES- SO I THINK EVEN
IN TESTIMONY SHOWING- THAT
PROPER RESPECT FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL THAT'S LOST RIGHT
THERE'S EVEN AT AT HALF A
PERCENT OF 1% OF THE MARKET
THAT'S STILL A LARGE PERCENTAGE
OF A MISSING. NATIVE AMERICAN
REMAINS THAT WILL NEVER BE ABLE
TO BE REPATRIATED BACK INTO THE
GROUND AND SO IF WE COULD GET A
LITTLE BIT MORE FOLLOW UP ON
MORE DATA ON THE MISSING- ITEMS
THAT CAN NO LONGER BE FOUND.
BUT ALSO IF YOU COULD A
ADDRESS- THAT THE TOPIC OF
UNKNOWN RIGHT WHEN SOMEONE
DOESN'T KNOW IT IN YOUR
ESTABLISHMENT WHERE THEY DON'T
KNOW WHERE A CULTURAL
AFFILIATION IS ARE THEY STILL
MATT MISS CLASSIFYING. THOSE
REMAINS TO GOING TO A- AN AREA
OF UNKNOWN. SO IF I COULD- TRY
TAKING ANSWER- THE FIRST POINT
THAT THAT YOU RAISED- CHAIRMAN
RAY MOST. I DO I DON'T WANT TO
LEAVE YOU WITH THE IMPRESSION
THAT THESE ITEMS ARE
IRREVOCABLY LOST- AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE IN ANY ANY SORT OF
LARGE COLLECTION. THINK OF IT
AS I MEAN IT'S NOT REALLY THE
APPROPRIATE ANALOGY I I'M AND I
AM TRYING TO BE VERY SENSITIVE
HERE. BUT THINK OF IT ALONG THE
LINES OF A- A FILE THAT HAS
BEEN YOU KNOW A PIECE OF PAPER
THAT HAS BEEN MIS FILED. I
DON'T WANT YOU TO THINK THAT
THEY'RE THEY'RE LOST FOREVER
THAT OUR INVENTORY AND WHAT WE
HAVE UNDER OUR CARE ARE NOT IN
ONE FOUR ONE CORRESPONDENCE.
BUT WERE WE ARE VERY CONFIDENT
THAT. IF WE SEARCHED WE COULD
FIND IT. BUT WE HAVE TO BE
CAREFUL ABOUT HOW WE SEARCH FOR
THESE THINGS BECAUSE IN LOOKING
FOR THESE THESE MESS MISSED
ITEMS WE MIGHT DO MORE HARM
THAN GOOD SO WE NEED TO DO THIS
IN A WAY WHICH IS VERY
CULTURALLY SENSITIVE AND IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE TRIBES.
AGAIN I AGREE WITH YOU- IT
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THESE ITEMS
AGAIN NOT NOT THE BEST
TERMINOLOGY TO USE PERHAPS- IS
IT BUT IS THERE'S A DESCENDANTS
WHO WHO CARES DEEPLY ABOUT THAT
AND- AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
GET OUR BOOKKEEPING IN ORDER
IF. WE ARE ABLE TO FIND THESE
ITEMS BUT IT I DON'T WANT YOU
TO COME AWAY WITH THE THOUGHT
OF. WILL NEVER FIND THEM
THEY'RE GONE FOREVER EVER THERE
IN OUR COLLECTION BUT WHERE
EXACTLY IN OUR COLLECTION IS
WHERE THE SORT OF MISSING ITEM
ISSUE KIND OF COMES UP NOW THE
OTHER THAT YOU RAISED IS ABOUT-
THE CULTURAL AFFILIATION AND
THE ISSUES OF THE HOW TO
CLASSIFY THAT THOSE YOU KNOW
TEN THOUSAND SETS OF HUMAN
REMAINS- SUMMER CULTURALLY
AFFILIATED SOME ARE. FOLLOWING
KIND OF STRICT LEGAL
TERMINOLOGY WERE DECIDED TO BE-
NOT AFFILIATED UP WE'VE
COMPLETELY CHANGED OUR APPROACH
TO THIS- WE'RE TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT THINGS LIKE OF THAT THE
THINGS THAT WE KNOW. WHERE WE
ARE THESE ITEMS WHERE THESE
READ- ANCESTRAL REMAINS WERE
FOUND. AND IF THAT'S IN A
TRADITIONAL TRIBAL LANDS LET'S
NOT WORRY ABOUT ARE THEY ARE
THE REMAINS OF NATIVE AMERICANS
ARE THEY REMAINS OF- SPANISH
SETTLERS ARE THE REMAINS OF A
EUROPEAN SETTLERS OF OTHER YOU
KNOW OTHER THINGS THERE'S A LOT
THAT WE CAN DETERMINE FROM THE
LOCATION FROM- THE WAY IN
WHICH- THE DOCUMENTATION I'M
ABOUT HOW THEY WERE THAT YOU
KNOW SORT OF FOUND- IT IN IT IN
THE GROUND OR IN IN THE
ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH THEY WERE
FOUND. THAT WILL HELP US
IDENTIFY THAT THEY ARE INDEED
NATIVE AMERICAN GRAVES AND BY
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT THE
CULTURAL- INFORMATION LIKE
WORLD ORAL TRADITIONS ORAL
HISTORIES THE GEOGRAPHIC
LOCATION AND SO ON. WE DON'T
NEED AN ARCHAEOLOGIST REPORT-
TO BE ABLE TO- REASONABLY
RENDERED DECISION THAT THE
START OF OUR ANCESTORS OF OTHER
NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITY SO.
WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF GOING
THROUGH OUR COLLECTION AND
RECAP CLASSIFYING IT BUT ARM
ARM ARM HIGHEST PRIORITY IS TO
JUST SORT OF ORGANIZE OUR OUT
REACH TO THOSE COMMUNITIES FOR
WHICH WE CAN DO A LARGE GROUP
REPATRIATION. BECAUSE OUR GOAL
IS TO ELIMINATE ARE ARE HANDLED
HANDLING OF ANCESTOR WHO
REMAINS IN A REASONABLE AMOUNT
OF TIME. SO BY WORKING WITH THE
ALONE A COMMUNITY OF WE'RE
HOPING THAT WE CAN YOU KNOW
LOOK AT THOSE- ITEMS THAT ARE
IN OUR COLLECTION THAT WERE
WERE ACTUALLY FOUND IN THE BAY
AREA COUNTIES AND USE THAT AS A
BASIS- JUST. CLASSIFYING LARGE
NUMBERS OF THOSE REMAINS AS
BEING ANCESTRAL REMAINS OF
NATIVE AMERICANS SO- LET ME
TELL YOU IT IS IT OUR GOAL IS
NOT TO LEAVE REMAINS
UNCLASSIFIED OUR GOAL IS TO
PRIORITIZE THAT PROCESS BY
WHICH WE CAN MOST RAPIDLY
REPATRIATE BUT TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT YOU KNOW THIS NEW
WAITING- YOU KNOW- CULTURALLY
SENSITIVE INFORMATION- ORAL
TRADITIONS GEOGRAPHIC LOCATION
WE BELIEVE THAT THAT WE CAN GET
TO A MUCH LARGER NUMBER OF A OF
IDENTIFIED- DELETED REMAINS-
THEN WE HAVE TO. HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO DO OR HAVE TRADITIONALLY
DONE IN THE PAST WELL THANK
YOU- THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND THANK YOU- TO
THE- PROVOST TOM FOR THE
TESTIMONY TO BRING US UP TO
DATE AND- WE WILL CONTINUE TO
HAVE- WHAT PROGRESS- HEARING
SO- CHAIR SALAS. ON THE
OUTCOMES OF A LOT OF THESE-
PENDING REQUIREMENTS THE THAT
CONTINUE TO EVOLVE. BUT WE
ALSO- NEED TO UNDERSTAND. THAT
THERE WAS A COMMENT THIS SAID
IT'S A PROCESS VERSUS POLICY
THE POLICY DRIVES THE PROCESS
AND I THINK THE POLICY IS WHAT
WE NEED TO GET TO. AT A
STATEWIDE LEVEL FOR ALL
UNIVERSITIES AND I'LL MAKE THE
COMMENT AGAIN- THE FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND NATIVE AMERICAN
REMAINS THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED IN THE UC. SYSTEM
WAS A SAMPLE POLLING OF UC
SYSTEM UC CAMPUSES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. IT WASN'T A
HUNDRED PERCENT- IDENTIFY ALL
THE REMAINS WITHIN THE UC
SYSTEM BUT JUST THAT SAMPLE
PAULINE OF THOSE UNIVERSITIES
UNCOVERED AND COVERED MANY
REMAINS AND WE'RE HEARING THAT
THAT THERE'S A EFFORT TO
IDENTIFY WHERE LOSS REMAINS
ARE. BUT WE'VE ALSO HAVE HEARD
FROM THE UC SYSTEM SOME UC'S
HAVE DONE A- HAVE WORKED OUT A
PROGRAM A POLICY THAT HAS BEEN
ABLE TO WORK. UC DAVIS WITHIN
THE LAST YEAR STARTED TO
REPATRIATE- TWO LOCAL TRIBES
AND UC BERKELEY- I'M ENCOURAGED
THAT IS FOLLOWING SUIT- TO THAT
ALSO. BUT AGAIN IT TOOK A PIECE
OF LEGISLATION TO ALLOW. ORAL
TRADITIONS FROM NATIVE AMERICAN
PEOPLE. AND ONE THING THAT IS
TRUE. THAT ALL THOSE REMAINS
THAT ARE THE ARCHIVES OF THE UC
SYSTEM AND DIFFERENT MUSEUMS UP
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE ONE THING THAT
IS TRUE. IS THE OWNERSHIP OF
THOSE REMAINS STAYS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA INDIAN PEOPLE AND
THE NATIVE AMERICAN PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES
WHO'S ALWAYS REMAINS- AND
ANCESTORS- ARE NEED TO BE
REPATRIATED AND REBURY SO WHEN
I THANK YOU FOR COMING FORWARD
AND OFFERING TESTIMONY AND
BEING TRUTHFUL ABOUT WHERE THE
PROCESS IS. AS WE CONTINUE TO
WORK TOGETHER TO MAKE URE THAT
WE ARE ABLE TO BE A BRING TO-
REALIZATION THE DAY THAT WE CAN
REPAY PATRIOT ALL THESE REMAINS
TO THE RIGHT FOR PEOPLE HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
THE UNITED STATES SO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. NEXT WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON OUR NEXT
PRESENTER. IS CHAIRMAN LEO
SISKIYOU OF THE TAICHI
ACUPUNCTURE. YOUR QUESTION
MISTER CHAIRMAN. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN GENERAL MOTORS. TEMAS
SALAS ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE YEAH
MY NAME IS LEO CISCO I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE TEST YOUR GOOD
PEOPLE AND WE ARE THANKFUL FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR
BEFORE YOU TODAY. AND TO SHARE
OUR EXPERIENCE IN
IMPLEMENTATION OF MACRA BY OUR
TRIBE. AND WE DO LIKE MANY
OTHER TRIBES SHARE THE
FRUSTRATION OF THE EMPTY
PROMISES RUN OUR TRIBE WE LIVE
WHERE A LARGER PART OF THE OKAY
GROUP OF THE OKAY LIVE WE LIVE
NOW IN WHAT IS CALLED THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY THE TAXI DRIVER
HIT FROM THE EARLY CALIFORNIA
MALICIOUS AND WAS ABLE TO THE
STATE AND THE CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA ON ONE OF THE
TRADITIONAL VILLAGES. THE TRIBE
HAS A STRONG CONNECTION TO THE
VALLEY. AND OUR ANCESTORS HAS
BEEN DEDICATED TO THE
PROTECTION AND REPRIEVE
REPATRIATION OF YOUR GOOD
ANCESTORS. FROM MANY
INSTITUTIONS INCLUDING UC
BERKELEY MY TRIBE HAS A LONG
EXPERIENCE WITH THE ONGOING
FAILURES OF THE UC NIAGARA
REPATRIATION PROCESS.
SPECIFICALLY WITH THE PHOEBE A.
HEARST MUSEUM OF ANTHROPOLOGY
AT UC BERKELEY WE MADE OUR
FIRST REQUEST FOR NAGRA
CONSULTATION ON AUGUST TWENTY
EIGHTH TWO THOUSAND TWO. ON
SEPTEMBER TWENTIETH TWO
THOUSAND TO UC BERKELEY CENTER
SANTA ROSA RANCHERIA THERE
PUBLISHED INVENTORIES. ALL OF
WHICH WERE CREATED WITHOUT THE
REQUIRED CONSULTATION THERE
WERE NO INVENTORIES FOR THE
NORTHERN VALLEY OKAY DESPITE
KNACK FOR BEING A PASSED A
DECADE BEFORE IN TWO THOUSAND
FOUR WE WROTE A LETTER OF
SUPPORT FOR UC BERKELEY. TO
RECEIVE A GRANT TO GET THEIR
INVENTORIES IN ORDER AND HOPE
IN IN GOOD FAITH THAT THE
PHOEBE HEARST MUSEUM WHAT
COMPLY WITH MACRO OUR HOPE WAS
THE PHOEBE HEARST MUSEUM WOULD
CREATE THEIR INVENTORIES WITH
THE REQUIRED CONSULTATION. WITH
THE TRIBES WHICH UNFORTUNATELY
NEVER HAPPENED IN FEBRUARY TWO
THOUSAND FOUR WE REQUESTED
REPATRIATION OF INDIVIDUALS
FROM TWENTY THREE SITES IN KERN
AND TULARE COUNTIES IN MARCH
TWO THOUSAND FOR A NOTICE OF
COMPLETION WAS PUBLISHED FOR
FIVE KERN COUNTY SITES WITHOUT
ANY TROUBLE CONSULTATION. ONE
OF THOSE SITES WAS CURRENT
FIFTY THREE. OF THE EIGHTY NINE
BURIAL RECORDS FOR KERR FIFTY
THREE. ONLY TWO OR CULTURAL
AFFILIATED AND REPATRIATED TO
THE CENTER OF THE RANCHERIA THE
REMAINING EIGHTY SEVEN BURIALS
WHICH WOULD BE ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY NINE THE VISUALS WERE
ONLY RECENTLY PLACE ON THE
CULTURALLY UNIDENTIFIABLE LIST
AFTER YEARS OF SANTA ROSA
REQUESTED THAT THEY BE
PARTIALLY IDENTIFIED THE PHOEBE
HEARST MUSEUM MAY THEIR
DENTURES DETERMINATION OF
AFFILIATION WITHOUT
CONSULTATION WITH TRIBES. WHICH
LED TO THE MAJORITY OF THEIR
SITES BEING DEEMED CULTURALLY
UNIDENTIFIABLE WITH CLEAR
PROVENANCE THEY WOULD PICK AND
CHOOSE THE RESOURCES AND
INFORMATION THAT THEY WOULD
CONSIDER IN ORDER TO HOLD ON TO
MANY COLLECTIONS AS THEY COULD
ORAL TRADITION AND TRIBAL
KNOWLEDGE WERE IGNORED ALMOST
COMPLETELY THE ONLY SOURCES
THEY WOULD USE FOR TRIBAL
KNOWLEDGE OR THEIR
ANTHROPOLOGIST NOT TRIBAL
PEOPLE INSTEAD THEY USE THE
LACK OF QUALIFIED EVIDENCE AS
OUR PRIMARY SOURCE OF EVIDENCE
IF THERE ARE ANY STUDIES THAT
SUGGEST THAT EARLIER GROUP.
THESE THAT TO SUPPORT OUR LACK
OF AFFILIATION FOR THE OKAY THE
AS MICHAEL MORADO. WHO BELIEVE
THERE MIGHT HAVE BEEN AN
EARLIER BOOK ON SPEAKING GROUP
PRIOR TO THE- KEPT MICHAEL
HYPOTHESIZE THAT THIS CHANGE
OCCURRED. ONE THOUSAND TO FIVE
HUNDRED BC AROUND THREE
THOUSAND YEARS AGO THEY USE
THIS LACK OF ARCHAEOLOGY
COMPLETED IN THIS AREA TO SAY
THAT ARCHEOLOGICAL WORK IN THE
SOUTHERN SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY HAS
FAILED TO PRODUCE A SECURE
TEMPORAL SEQUENCE FOR
PREHISTORIC CULTURES OF THIS
AREA THEREFORE THE REMAINS WILL
BE DETERMINED TO BE CULTURALLY
UNIDENTIFIABLE BECAUSE THEY
INTENSELY LACK INFORMATION
ALTHOUGH A LACK OF EVIDENCE
COULD SELL LOGICAL IT IS
APPLIED IN THE MOST IRRATIONAL
WAYS FOR EXAMPLE FRESNO FORTY
NINE IS THE TAXI VILLAGE. ARE
YOU W. THE AREA OF THE KIT FOX
THE BURNELL FAMILY CAME FROM
THIS VILLAGE AND THEIR
DESCENDANTS STILL LIVE ON THE
RANCHERIA THE TRIBE HAS
DOCUMENTATION OF THIS VILLAGE
IT WAS RECORDED BY CLOVER GAIN
AND JAY WERE LAW ALL OF WHOM
WORKED FOR BERKELEY WHILE THEY
GATHER THEIR INFORMATION. THE
HUMOR LANDS REMAINS WERE
COLLECTED BY HUGHES THE MASSEY
IN NINETEEN THIRTY NINE FOR
BERKELEY AND USE A MASSIVE
SERVER REPORT THEY SPOKE TO
INDIANS OVER NOW WHO ACCORDING
TO THE REPORT WAS THE LAST
SURVIVING TETCHY INFORMANT FROM
THIS VILLAGE THE HUMAN REMAINS
WERE COLLECTED CAME FROM GORDON
KANE'S COLLECTION THESE REMAINS
WERE SO RECENT THAT WAS STILL
ORGANIC MATERIALS AND GLASS
BOTTLES WITH THE BURIALS AND
YET THIS SITE WAS CONSIDERED
CULTURALLY UNIDENTIFIABLE.
BECAUSE IT LACKED
ARCHAEOLOGICAL EVIDENCE AND IT
WAS NOT A CLEAR LINGUISTIC
CONNECTION TO A CURRENT TRIED
AGAIN BECAUSE ACCORDING TO MIKE
MORADO THERE MAY HAVE BEEN AN
EARLIER GROUP THAT EXISTED
THREE THOUSAND YEARS PRIOR. BUT
ORGANIC MATERIAL DOES NOT LAST
THREE THOUSAND YEARS. NOR WERE
THE GLASS BOTTLES DURING THAT
TIME EITHER DESPITE ALL THIS
THIS SITE REMAINS ON THE
CULTURE AYE UNIDENTIFIABLE
LIVES TO THIS DAY SANTA ROSA
SARAH'S GREATEST CHALLENGE WITH
THE UC KNACK FOR PROCESS TODAY
INVOLVES THE KINGS COUNTY
REMAINS THE PHOEBE A. HEARST
MUSEUM OF ANTHROPOLOGY AT
BERKELEY COULD NOT PRODUCE AN
INVENTORY OF THE KINGS COUNTY
REMAINS UNTIL TWO THOUSAND FIVE.
THE AT EIGHT SITES AND TWENTY
FOUR INDIVIDUALS FROM KINGS
COUNTY. KINGS 1-478-910-1219
THE MAJORITY OF THESE SITES ARE
WITHIN TEN MILES OF OUR
RANCHERIA THEY'RE ALL RECORDED
AND COLLECTED BY HOUSTON MASSEY
IN NINETEEN THIRTY NINE. ALL
THE SITES ARE WITHIN
TRADITIONAL TAXI TERRITORY ALL
SIDES HAVE BEEN DETERMINED TO
BE CULTURALLY UNIDENTIFIABLE AS
PREVIOUSLY STATED THE CURRENT
SHARIA WAS ESTABLISHED TO HIDE
THE TAXI FROM THE EARLY
CALIFORNIA MALICIOUS IN
EIGHTEEN FIFTY EIGHT ONE
MELISSA RABBI CAPTAIN ANSWERING
GATHERED UP TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
TAXI AND THE TUNA TWOS AND
CHECKED INTO THE KINGS RIVER
FARM RESERVATION KINGS ONE WAS
ON MR ISRAEL IS PROPERTY HE WAS
INTERVIEWED BY HUGHES AMASSING.
THESE THREE MOUNTS WITH
ATTACHING VILLAGE YOU'RE GONNA
ONE OF THE LARGEST ALWAYS ON
THE RANCHERIA THE THOMASES OUR
FROM THIS VILLAGE YEAH THIS
SITE IS DEEMED TO BE CULTURALLY
UNIDENTIFIABLE. BY THE PHOEBE
HEARST MUSEUM. KINGS FOR WAS A
VILLAGE OF THE WHOLE TIME WHICH
IS THE ANCESTRAL HOME OF MADE
SENSE OF THE TRIBES CISCO
FAMILY. MYSELF INCLUDED MY
FAMILY CAME FROM THE VILLAGE
AND WAS RECORDED BY GAINING
CLOVER FOR UC BERKELEY ALTHOUGH
WE HAVE CLOSE KINSHIP
UNDERSTANDING OF THE VILLAGE
APARTMENTS ON. THIS SITE IS
DEEMED TO BE CULTURALLY
UNIDENTIFIABLE BY THE PHOEBE
HEARST MUSEUM FOR NIAGARA
PURPOSES. KINGS KINGS SEVEN
THROUGH TEN OR THE TAXI VILLAGE
A GUY WAS LIKE YOU. THE RED
WING BLACKBIRDS YOU HAVE THESE
SITES ARE DEEMED CULTURALLY
UNIDENTIFIABLE. THOSE RECORD AS
APACHE VILLAGE BY GAME FOR
BERKELEY KINGS TWELVE IS ATTACH
ABILITY OF YOUR MAIL TO CATCH
FISH BY HAND. AND WAS RECORDED
BY CLOVER AND DREAM GAINES
KISSED ME FOR BERKELEY UC
BERKELEY DOESN'T HAVE ENOUGH
EVIDENCE TO CLOSELY A PHILLY
OUR ANCESTORS BURIED THERE TO
OUR TRIBE KINGS TEN WAS
PREVIOUSLY CULTURALLY
AFFILIATED AND REPATRIATED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION IN JANUARY TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN. HEARST MUSEUM
STAFF CLOSELY AFFILIATE OF THE
SITE TO THE TAXI DRIVER IN JULY
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN CHEN Y. UCB
REPATRIATION COMMITTEE CHAIR
DENOUNCED THE CULTURE
AFFILIATION RECOMMENDATION
AFTER THAT THE FEVERS MUSEUM
NECRO STAFF WAS RE ORGANIZED IN
TIME PAST IN TWO THOUSAND TEN
THE TRY FORMALLY REQUESTED
REPATRIATION OF ALL KINGS
COUNTY SITES WE PROVIDE ALL WE
PROVIDE AN ORAL HISTORY TO
CLOSELY AFFILIATE THESE
ANCESTORS TO OUR MODERN DAY
TRIED BUT WE WERE TOLD THAT WE
NEED TO PROVIDE MORE EVIDENCE
SPECIFICALLY ARCHAEOLOGICAL
RESOURCES OF MORE CURRENT
EXCAVATIONS. AS TRIBAL LINES OF
EVIDENCE WERE NOT STRONG ENOUGH
TO PHILLY THESE PEOPLE TO THE
TAXI DRIVER AGAIN THEY REFUSED
TO ACCEPT TRAVEL KNOWLEDGE AND
HISTORY OF OUR CONNECTION TO
THESE ANCESTRAL VILLAGES.
BECAUSE ARCHAEOLOGISTS COULD
NOT AGREE ON A TIME OF OUR
OCCUPATION OF THE REGION. IN
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN. AS A TRIBE
REFUSED TO PROVIDE MORE
ARCHAEOLOGICAL EVIDENCE. THE
PHOEBE HEARST MUSEUM SENT US A
LETTER STATING THAT WE WOULD
PULL. ALL THE OTHER AFFILIATED
STRIVE TO SEE THE SUPPORT SEE
IF THEY SUPPORT OUR CLIENTS
SANTA ROSA RENTERIA TOOK OUR
CONCERNS TO NATIONAL MACRO BUT
NOTHING WAS DONE IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE WE TOOK A
CONCERNS ABOUT UC BERKELEY TO A
NATIONAL NECRO COMMITTEE
MEETING BUT AGAIN NOTHING WAS
DONE THE TRIBE PROVIDED AT THE
POLITICAL REPORTS TO SUPPORT
CLAIM TO THESE ANCESTORS. BUT
AGAIN WE WERE DENIED BECAUSE
THEY TRY FAILED TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION RELEVANT TO THE
DATING OF THESE REMAINS THAT
JULY TWENTY THIRD TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE LETTER THE TRIBE WAS
TOLD THAT THE UC CONSIDER THIS
MATTER CLOSED IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN THE TRIBE REQUESTED
THE TRANSFER OF CONTROL OF THE
TWENTY FOUR TOUCH INDIVIDUALS
UNDER THE TEN A LIBERAL. BASED
UPON GEOGRAPHIC LOCATION
DESPITE SIGNING FOR THE
CERTIFIED LETTER THE PHOEBE
HEARST MUSEUM SAID THEY NEVER
RECEIVED THE LETTER AND REFUSED
TO ABIDE BY THE NINETY DAY TIME
LIMIT FOR A RESPONSE LATER THEY
DECIDED THE PHOEBE HEARST
MUSEUM NEEDED TO CONSULT WITH
TWENTY TWO TRIBES WAS THEY
FOUND ACTORS WEBSITE AS
ASSOCIATED WITH TREATIES SIGNED
A KINGS COUNTY BEFORE THE
REPATRIATION COULD OCCUR
HOWEVER. MANY OF THOSE TRIBES
HAD NO CONNECTION TO KINGS
COUNTY AT ALL THE TRY WORK FOR
A YEAR AND A HALF TO THIS TO
THIS VIEW THE SOUTHERN TRIBES
CONNECTION TO THE TREATY SIGNED
ON THE KING'S RIVER IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN NATIONAL
MACRO SUPPORT THE REMOVAL OF
THE SOUTHERN TRIBES FROM A LIST
OF TRIBES CULTURALLY AFFILIATED
WITH THE AREA IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN THE PHOEBE HEARST
MUSEUM STATED THAT THE TRIBE
HAD NEVER COMPLETED THE
PAPERWORK TO CONSULT EVEN THE
TRIBE THIS A LARGE CONSULTATION
SANTA ROSA RENTERIA HAD NO
CHOICE BUT TO ME WITH EVERY
SINGLE REQUEST TO TRY AND
OBTAINMENT ATTAIN A SIGNATURE
OF SUPPORT IT TOOK YEARS ONCE
WE FINALLY RECEIVED THE LAST
LETTER THE TRIBE REQUESTED A
TRANSFER OF CONTROL OF OUR
ANCESTORS AT WHICH POINT PHOEBE
HEARST MUSEUM SENT A LETTER
STATING. THAT THE TRIBE HAD TO
PROVE THAT WE ARE NATIVE
AMERICANS NOW IN APRIL TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN SANTA ROSA
RANCHERIA ALONG WITH MANY OTHER
TRIES WENT TO A MEETING WITH UC
BERKELEY TO DISCUSS THE
DISRESPECT OF ALL TRAVEL PEOPLE
AT THE HANDS OF BERKELEY.
THROUGH THEIR FAILURE WITH NAPA
IN MARCH TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
YOKA DELEGATES WENT TO MEET.
WITH THE CHANCE TO REGARD THE
FAILURE TO COMPLY WITH NIAGARA
FINALLY IN AUGUST TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THE NOTICE OF AMATORY
OF COMPLETION WAS PUBLISHED FOR
THE KINGS COUNTY REMAINS THESE
PEOPLE WERE NEVER CULTURALLY
AFFILIATED TO THE OKAY OR
DETACHING BUT THEY WERE FINALLY
RETURNED. WHEN THE OKAY
COALITION ARRIVE TO BRING THEIR
ANCESTORS HOME. THEY WERE TOLD
TO BRING THEIR OWN BOXES. AND
PHOEBE HEARST MUSEUM STAFF
SKANDERBORG CODES IN FRONT OF
THEM AS IF THEY WERE AT A
GROCERY STORE AND THEIR PEOPLE
OR SOMETHING MERCHANDISE IN ONE
LESS DISGUSTING DISPLAY OF
DISRESPECT NOW THERE'S NO
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE IN THE
TRIBES ARE TOLD THAT IT WOULD
TAKE A COUPLE HUNDRED MORE
YEARS TO BE FULLY COMPLY WITH
THE EXTRA THIRTY YEARS AFTER
THE ACT WAS PASSED. WELL OVER
THREE THOUSAND OF OUR PEOPLE.
REMAIN IN THE UC BERKELEY
STORAGE WE MUST ORK TOGETHER
TO FIX THIS TERRIBLE TRAVESTY
AND REQUIRE FULL COMPLIANCE
WITH NIAGARA AND CAL KNACK FOR.
NOW WHAT WE ARE AT OUR OUR
PEOPLE ARE VERY TIRED OF
HEARING THE INTO PROMISES WE
WANT RESULTS. IN OUR PEOPLE
THEY'RE NOT MERCHANDISE THEY'RE
NOT ITEMS THEY'RE NOT PROPERTY
THERE ARE ANCESTORS IN THE V.
THEY DID THEY DESERVE TO BE
TREATED WITH RESPECT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN FOR- YOUR
HEARTFELT TESTIMONY IN
IDENTIFYING- THE PROCESS THAT
THE BURDEN OF PROOF RELIES ON
THE VERY PEOPLE WHO IS THOSE
REMAINS BELONG TO AND THOSE ARE
AREAS THAT THE LEGISLATURE AND
WITH THE COLLEAGUES HERE ARE
ENCOURAGED TO FIX AND BALANCE
IT OUT WE DID THAT WITH A BILL
THAT BROUGHT ORAL TRADITION AND
TRADITIONAL KNOWLEDGE TO EQUAL
FOOTING. WITH THOSE AND MUSEUM
DIRECTORS AND UC SYSTEM SO WE
HAVE TO CONTINUE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT CONTINUES TO HAPPEN
AND IF YOU COULD- CHAIRMAN- HOW
MANY YEARS IT TAKES TO GET
THOSE REMAINS BACK FOR PROPER
REPAIR. I DON'T HAVE THE EXACT
TIMELINE BUT IT WAS IT WAS A
VERY LONG TIME THANK YOU FOR
THE YEARS YOU'RE SPEAKING ABOUT
THE NON TACTIC YEAH. NOW I
DON'T HAVE THE EXACT DATES ON
THAT BUT IT WAS. IT WAS QUITE
SOME TIME THANK YOU FOR THAT
ANY COMMENTS. QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE. CHAIRMAN SALAS THANK
YOU THANK YOU SERVICES GO FOR
BEING HERE AND TESTIFYING TODAY
GIVING US A CLEAR TIMELINE OF
WHAT- TRIBES ARE GOING THROUGH
WHEN THEY'RE TRYING TO GET-
REPATRIATE. TRYING TO GET
THINGS REPATRIATED- THAT'S WHAT
I THINK WE WERE TRYING TO
CONVEY TO THE UC SYSTEM AS WELL
IS- THE FRUSTRATION THAT THIS
BODY- FILLS WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY
FELT BY BY THE TRIBAL MEMBERS I
BELIEVE NOT ONLY THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY YOU KNOW
YOU TALKED ABOUT THIS YOU KNOW
THE YOU NEED TO PROVIDE MORE
EVIDENCE I THINK YOU SAID IN
TWENTY TEN. AND KIND OF GO TO
CHAIRMAN ROBERTS IS- QUESTION
AND BUT YOU KNOW YOU DIDN'T
RECEIVE A RANGE INTEL WAS A
TWENTY. SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN- BUT
WHAT I WANT TO ASK IS YOU KNOW
GIVEN THE TESTIMONY YOU HEARD
EARLIER TODAY HOWEVER YOUR
INTERACTIONS BEEN THIS YEAR OUR
SINCE THE OUT IT'S BEEN
PUBLISHED WE'VE BEEN HOLDING
THESE HEARINGS. HAVE YOU FOUND
IT EASIER HAVE YOU FOUND A MORE
DIFFICULT. I HAVE YOU FOUND
THEM PUTTING UP MORE OBSTACLES
LIKE THEY DID. IN THE PAST SO
THAT WE CAN TRY TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THOSE ISSUES- MOVING FORWARD
WE FEEL THAT THE COMMUNICATION
HAS REMAINED THE SAME. THE
OBSTACLES STILL VERY MUCH
EXIST. AND TO BE QUITE HONEST
TO WHAT WE HEAR TODAY NO HE MAY
NOT KNOW THE ENTIRE STORY OF
HIS STAFF. BUT WE KNOW THE
RESULTS THAT THE COMMUNICATION
NEEDS TO BE BETTER AND TO BE
QUITE HONEST WITH YOU- GERMAN
SAUCE IT SOUNDS LIKE LIP
SERVICE. GOT IT I UNDERSTAND I
APPRECIATE THAT BECAUSE AS WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE FOLLOW UP
DISCUSSIONS WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE TEAR DOWN THOSE
OBSTACLES. TO MAKE IT A LOT
EASIER TO WE PASSED
LEGISLATION- PREVIOUSLY BUT- WE
STILL WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE. ACCELERATING THE RETURN OF
THESE REMAIN SO THEY CAN BE
TREATED WITH RESPECT AND
DIGNITY AND APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY THANK YOU MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR MASSAGE AROMA
LISTENED AGAIN. YOU KNOW ALL
THEY HAVE TO DO IS CONSULT WITH
THE TRIBES YOU KNOW THOSE ARE
PEOPLE SO WE KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
TO DO. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN- FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. AND LAYING OUT THE
FRUSTRATIONS THAT- TRIBES FEEL
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHEN TRYING TO- HAVE
REMAINS REPATRIATED BACK FOR
PROPER REBURIAL THANK YOU FOR
THAT. OUR NEXT- TESTIMONY WILL
COME FROM- CHAIR WOMAN LOUISE
MARANDA ROMERO'S SHE'S
CHAIRWOMAN OF THE LOANEE COSTA
NON S. LINE NATION. AMISH SHE
READY TO GIVE HER TESTIMONY.
CHAIRMAN ROBERT AND GERMAN
FELLOWS I AM AVAILABLE- OKAY
THANK YOU FOR INCLUDING ME- I
WOULD COME OUT AND SAY NEEDS
NOT YOU I THINK THE CONNECTION
I'M A SOUND NOT HOW EASY ACT UP
I MEAN I MEAN CHECK ASSEMBLY
WHAT CONCEPT AHEAD OF TIME
HELLO NEED NO ONE ANSWERED IN
THE NATION. AHEAD OF TIME THE
GREATER MONTEREY. BAY AREA AND
SO- I AM CHAIR WERE FOR ANOTHER
BECAUSE KNOW AND LONG WE ARE AT
THE END PEOPLE OF MY HOW MANY
WITH THE MORE TWENTY TRIBAL
AREAS AND MANY VILLAGES WITHIN
THOSE AREAS THAT INCLUDE THE
TRIBAL AREAS OF CARMEL MISSION
AS WELL AS SOME OF THE DEAD
MISSION- TODAY CUCCO TALKING
DOWN REPATRIATION AND THE
CLAIMING OF OUR ANCESTORS. AND
I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS THAT WE CAN
DO- IT'S VERY HARD BECAUSE
OTHER INDIVIDUALS- NON NAVY DO
NOT UNDERSTAND. THE LOVE AND
CARE THAT WE GIVE TO OUR
ANCESTORS EVEN TODAY I HAVE
SENT TO- NOTIFICATION TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF BERKELEY THAT
OCEAN WAS AVAILABLE AND-
REQUESTED CONSULTATION I
RECEIVED A CALL AND EMAIL FROM
A DOCTOR TORAH. AND SAID THAT
HE WOULD GOING TO BE LEAVING
FOR- SOME TIME AND THAT HE
WOULD CONTACT ME OR WE COULD
GET IN CONTACT UPON HIS RETURN
AND I HAVE NOT HEARD FROM THEM
THAT WAS IN MAY- I AM AWARE
THAT THERE WERE REMAINS OF
SEVEN OF OUR ANCESTORS. THAT
WERE FOUND WITH THE AND ISABEL
MEADOWS AB IN THE SOUTHERN AREA
OF FROM MIAMI. TELL ME- WE HAD
BEEN THANK WE AS THE MLB'S
AVERAGE A BAD AREA M. THE MOST
LIKELY DESCENDANTS AND DIDN'T
HAVEANY CEREMONY AT AT BROKE
TO LEAD TO RETURN THOSE
ANCESTORS- BOB D. FORCED THREE
BACKED OUT AND I BELIEVE THAT
THOSE ANCESTORS ARE STILL IN
BERKELEY AND HOPEFULLY CAN BE
CONTACTED I AM NOT AWARE OF ANY
COMMITTEE ON WE'D HAVE NOT BEEN
INCLUDED. OF OR WE HAVE NOT
BEEN ASSIGNED BY THE NATIVE
COMMISSION TO WORK WITH
BERKELEY- SO I'M NOT SURE WHAT
HAPPENED THERE OR WHO IS
REPRESENTING OUR AREA AND SOME
PEOPLE MIGHT THINK THAT BECAUSE
WE HAVE THE NAME ALLOW ME THAT
WE ARE ALL ONE GROUP. THERE
THERE ARE MANY THERE ARE READ
OF DIFFERENT TERRITORIES WHICH
WE SUPPORT THE MORE WHAT I NEED
THE- FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA AND THE I MODE SOON FROM
THE LOWER LOWER- BAY AREA AND-
THEN THERE IS ARI'S WITHIN
MONTEREY COUNTY- ALL OF WHICH
INCLUDES BIG SUR AND- OF MANY
OTHER MODERATE AND- OF OTHER
AREAS- WE WORKED- REUTERS TWO
YEARS- WELL THAT WAS ACTUALLY
MORE. WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
ARMY TRYING TO THE OF
REPATRIATE AND BURY ALL OF OUR
ANCESTORS AND WE'VE GIVEN AMY-
PARCEL. OF TO BE BURIED
ANCESTORS. ON THE LOWER
PRESIDIO AND DINNER I COULD
HAVE BEEN WAY OBVIOUS THE U.
OKAY INSHA WHICH IS THE THE SAN
ROSA TOUCH CABLE NOW CHU CHANCY
TOTALLY RIVER AND THE SAN IN
THAT SPENDING ISSUE MATH WHO IS
ARE TRYING AND- IDENTIFIED AS
THE INDIGENOUS PEOPLE OF THAT
AREA- EVEN THOUGH- B. B. YOU
KNOW I DID STATES GOVERNMENT
DOES NOT RECOGNIZE US SO WE
COULD NOT EVEN CLAIM OUR
ANCESTORS WE NEEDED A FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBE TO CLAIM THEM.
TO PICK THEM UP IN OUR
ANCESTORS WERE SPREAD AROUND
CALIFORNIA IT TOOK MUCH TIME
FOR THE ARMY TO COLLECT THEM WE
MET WITH THE PENTAGON WE
BECAUSE THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
EVER THAT THEY WERE GOING TO BE
REALLY VERY ON EIGHT OF. ARMY
BASE AND- WHEN I WAS ASKED WHY
DO YOU WANT THEM BURIED ON
MIAMI DADE I SAID I DON'T I
WANT THEM BACK WITH OUR
HOMELAND THE BASE IS ON OUR
HOME PLANET AND- THAT WAS VERY
IMPORTANT THAT INDIVIDUALS
UNDERSTAND THAT OF OUR HOMELAND
AND THAT'S THE PRESIDIO ONE OF
OUR LARGEST VERY BURIAL GROUND.
AND THE DISRESPECT OF THE
CITIES AND THE GOVERNMENT IN
THAT AREA THAT DON'T WANT TO-
WORK WITH THE TRIED OF ME
REPATRIATE THAT WAS THE FIRST
TIME EVER AND WE ARE VERY
GRATEFUL TO THE OUTPUT-
POLLUTION- FOR STANDING WITH US
WHICH MADE THAT POSSIBLE IS
THAT WITH ALL FEDERAL- AND IT
WAS EXTREMELY HARD LIKE I SAID
IT TOOK YEARS. AND- AND WE-
FINALLY DID VERY AND THE ARMY
DID RECORDED BECAUSE THAT'S THE
FIRST TIME EVER THEY HAD WORKED
WITH TRYING TO END IN REPAIRING
ON AN ARMY BASE- WE'VE WORKED
WITH THE CITY OF MONTEREY- AND-
THERE WERE ANCESTORS FOUNDED IN
THE ROAD. AND WE WANT WE DIDN'T
WANT TO LEAVE THEM IN UNDER A
LEAKING SEWER PIPE AND THE CITY
DIDN'T WANT US TO MOVE THEM AND
WE WORK WITH THE NATIVE
HERITAGE COMMISSION AND LOCAL
WE THAT. THEIR ATTORNEY
ASSISTED AS AS WE WERE ASSIGNED
AS THE MOST LIKELY DESCENDED.
FOR A YEAR AND THE ONLY REASON
WE WERE EVER ABLE TO BE MOVED
DOWN SISTERS AND BURIED IT
REBURY THEM WAS BECAUSE THE
CITY CALLED UP ONE DAY AND SAID
THAT THEY WERE PAYING A LOT OF
MONEY TO HAVE STEEL PLATES
COVERING THE OPENING. AND SO-
WE WERE PROVIDED A SMALL AREA
WITHIN A NATIVE OR NON CEMETERY
THAT COULD BE- COULD BE VERY
ALL ANCESTORS WITHIN THE CITY
LIMITS OF MONTEREY WE'VE ALSO-
COME TO AN AGREEMENT WITH THE
CITY OF PACIFIC GROVE OR AS A
NATIVE CEMETERY THAT WE ARE
REPAIRING OUR ANCESTORS FROM
THAT TRIBAL AREA AND WE HAVE
WRITTEN AGREEMENTS THAT THAT
THERE WILL BE NO PAYMENT TO THE
TRIBE AS I MENTIONED OF THEIR
MANY IN EQUITIES THAT WE DO NOT
HAVE OF. COMPARED TO A
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBE WE
DON'T HAVE MONEY TO PAY FOR
THEM WE DON'T HAVE MONEY TO PAY
FOR THE OPENING OF THE CLOSINGS
TO BE VERY AYE ANCESTORS AND-
WE- CONTINUOUSLY WORK AND THEY
HAVE ASSISTED US. AND WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO BE VERY ALL THE
CITY OF PACIFIC GROVE. I WANT
THEM ON DISPLAY- LAST JANUARY-
THE CITY OF MUSEUM- I HAD A
MEETING WITH THEM I WENT TO THE
MEETING NINE THE DIRECTOR AND
THE ASSISTANT OF HAD RECEIVED
THE APPROVAL TO TURN OVER ALL
OF THE HUMAN REMAINS THAT OF
COURSE FOR BURIAL- I WAS
CERTAIN THAT THE TABLE AND I
WAS SHOCKED. THAT THEY SAID
WHEN DO YOU WANT THEM AND I
SAID RIGHT NOW I'LL TAKE THEM
BUT I'M IN MY CAR I'M NOT
GIVING ANYBODY DIDN'T THE TIME
TO CHANGE THEIR MONEY. UP
SIGNED THE AGREEMENT THAT WE
TOOK THEM WE HAD OTHER A LARGE
BURIAL INVITED ALL OF OUR
TRIBAL MEMBERS- COMPARED THE
ANCESTORS AND- IT THE SAME TO
SAY FROM ONE MEETING TO THE
NEXT EVEN EVEN THOUGH WE SPOKE
A LOT AND WE IDENTIFIED WHO WE
WERE WE HOPE I HAVE NO PROBLEM
NUVEEN WE ARE MY GREAT
GRANDFATHER THOMAS ALTURAS
MARANDA WAS IDENTIFIED BY C.
EAT CALCIUM IN NINETEEN OH SIX
AS THE ONLY FAMILY JIMENEZ WIFE
OF AND EACH OF THEIR NATURE OF
THE ESALEN AS THE MONTEREY BAND
OF MONTEREY AT THE SERVER RANGE
VIA AND PROVING THIS
INFORMATION IS TO SAY WHO WE
CAN RETURN OUR ANCESTORS ANNA
ANYTIME WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
BURIALS THE CITIES HAVE AGREED
TO- OPEN UP. THE NEEDS AND
ALLOW US TO THE ENDS THAT WE
HAVE NOT HEARD FROM BOTH LIKE I
SAID THAT WOULD IN MAY IN
FEBRUARY I HAD AN ADDITIONAL
BACK SURGERY AND HAVE NOT BEEN
CONTACTED AGAIN I'VE SEEN
PLENTY OF EMAILS- BUT NONE OF
THEM REQUEST A CONSULTATION- I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT- WE
PREPARED THOSE ANCESTORS FOR
REBURIAL AND THERE WAS LIKE TEN
TRIBES THAT WENT WITH ME- A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM DIFFERENT
TRIBES WE WHAT AT BERKELEY. OR
THE BACKUP AND LYFT HOME
FRIENDS- STUDY NINE LANGUAGES
AND- WE ARE PREPARED THEM WITH
GIFTS. AND I BELIEVE THEY'RE
STILL THERE AND GOING INTO THE
BASE. IT'S UNBELIEVABLE TO BE
AMOUNT REMAINS THANK YOU CAN A
KIND STOCK AND STACKS OF ARE
VOTE BUT A AHEAD OF PAY AND. I
LISTENING TO THE OTHERS ANOTHER
BIT CONFUSED ON HOW THEY CANNOT
ACT SOME OF REMAIN WHEN EACH
SIDE IS AN THEY KNEW WHAT THEY
WERE SO THAT THAT'S MANY THERE
AND WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT WE ARE
RETURNING THOUSANDS TO BE ALONE
AND I AM HOPEFUL THAT THEY
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
DIFFERENT AREAS OF BALONEY SO
IF THERE'S- SOME REMAINS THAT
ARE ALONI BUT A MONTEREY COUNTY
THAT YEAH YOU YOU SHOULD BE
RETURNED TO MONTEREY COUNTY AND
IF THEY'RE FROM SAN BENITO
SANTA CRUZ RETURNED THERE AND
THEN OF COURSE WE TRYING TO HE
THE MORE MY NOMINATE- IN THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY- THIS IS HARD
WORK THIS IS HARD WORK FOR WHAT
I KNOW ON RECOGNIZED RIGHT WE
DON'T HAVE THE FUNDING WE DON'T
HAVE THE WAY WHEN I WHEN I READ
VERY. I WOULD BOARD VOTES MY
MEETING IT'S ON MY OWN BONDS AS
TO PREPARE BECAUSE THAT'S THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING THAT WE
CAN DO IS THAT OUR ANCESTORS
OUT OF THESE MUSEUM AND THE
HARD PART IN WHEN YOU PICK THEM
UP I NEED SEE THAT THEY'VE
WRITTEN ON THESE PHONES THAT
THEY I DON'T KNOW IF I AM WITH
NUMBER THAT'S WHAT THEY THINK
OF A N. M. IT'S WRONG A WE PRAY
WE WISH THE THERE WAS A WAIT
TAKE THESE NUMBERS OFF OF THE
REMAINS OF OUR ANCESTORS BUT WE
CAN'T BECAUSE THEN WE WOULD
LOSE THAT MUCH MORE OF THE
REMAIN SO WE NEED TO THEN HAVE
NO CHOICE BUT TO BE VERY
THOUSAND BUT THE NUMBER. IT'S
IMPORTANT OF THAT ALL OF OUR
ANCESTORS AB VERY. I DON'T KNOW
WHAT ELSE TO SAY IT'S A LOT OF
WORK- WE NEED TO WORK WITH THE
NATIVE HERITAGE COMMISSION IF
THEY'VE SET UP A COMMITTEE OR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO DETERMINE-
WHOSE ANCESTORS THOUGH WHERE- I
TRIED WE PRESENT OVER SIX
HUNDRED TRIBAL MEMBERS. AND
EACH OF THEM HAVE HAD THEIR
GENEALOGY GROUP. AND WE ALL
REALLY NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE CAN SHARE THAT WITH
EVERYONE. OF WHERE WE COME FROM
AND YET INDIVIDUALS THAT MY
NAME ONLY AS A FAMILY ARE
RECEIVING OUR ANCESTORS AND IT
TURNS OUT TO BE MORE
INFORMATION TODAY WAS THE FIRST
TIME I HEARD THAT THE NATIVE
HERITAGE COMMISSION HAD
ASSIGNED MEMBERS ORTIZ
COMMITTEES THAT BERKELEY AND- I
WILL BE CHECKING INTO THAT
BECAUSE I NEED. I NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR ANCESTORS COME
HOME GUARD ARE HOMELESS. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY IS THAT
CONCLUDES YOUR TESTIMONY
CHAIRWOMAN YEAH I THINK THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR- IN THE
PICTURE THAT FACES SO MANY- OF
OUR PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- WHEN DEALING WITH
CALIFORNIA INDIAN TRIBES AND WE
ALL AGREE THAT THE REPATRIATION
OF THOSE ARE AN ARCHIVE SUCH AS
THE UC SYSTEM MUSEUMS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SHOULD BE ABLE TO
GET BACK INTO AN A EXPEDITED
FASHION TO THE RIGHTFUL OWNERS
FOR PROPER REBURIAL. IN THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING UP- THE
DIFFERENT CLAN- SYSTEMS THERE
PARTICULARLY WITH THE LOANEE.
BUT IT ALSO BRINGS UP THE- THE
AREAS OF MANY PEOPLE SEE
RESERVATIONS TODAY BUT- FAIL TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THE BAY AREA
MONTEREY THAT HAS NOW BECAME A
LARGE. COMMUNITY COUNTY CITY
THAT THERE'S INDIAN PEOPLE-
THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND ITS THOSE
REMAINS THE STILL ARE IN
ARCHIVES IS THOSE REMAINS THAT
WE'RE HEARING HAVE BEEN
MISCLASSIFIED OR EVEN LOST
THEIR TRYING TO- RETREAT BUT
EACH ONE OF THOSE REPRESENTS
THE ANCESTORS OF OUR PEOPLE AND
OUR BIGGEST JOB TOGETHER AS
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE IS TO ENSURE
THE REPATRIATION PROCESS MOVES
FORWARD I WANT TO THANK YOU
CHAIRWOMAN- REMEMBER AS FOR.
TESTIFYING TODAY ON THOSE THOSE
ASPECTS THAT WERE THERE I DO
HAVE A FOLLOW UP QUESTION YOU
MENTIONED BECAUSE THIS HEARING
IS NOW LOOKING AT WHAT THE
AUDIT REPORT MOVE FORWARD AS
FAR AS MAKING SURE THAT THEIR-
WORKING ON PROCESSES TO HAVE
REPATRIATION MOVE FORWARD BUT
YOU MENTION. THAT IN MAY OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IF I HEARD
CORRECTLY YOU MADE A REQUEST
TO- UC BERKELEY AND HAVE NOT
HEARD BACK FROM THEM. OKAY I
STATED TO. OF NINE SO MANY MEN
AND DR THOMAS IN TORAH-
ADVISING THAT- SINCE I HAD NOT
RECOVERED FROM THE BACK
SURGERY- AND THAT IF THEY WERE
DOING A RECORDING I WOULD HAVE
PEACE APPRECIATE BEING PROVIDED
WITH A LINK TO WATCH AND I
STATED IN THE EMAIL OCEAN IS
AVAILABLE TO PARTICIPATE AND
CONSULTATION WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF BERKELEY NINETY
CORRECT COMMITTEE I LOOK
FORWARD TO SPEAKING WITH YOU
AND RECEIVING ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION THE THIRD HERE WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S-
AN AREA THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
ADDRESSING THAT THERE IS FOLLOW
UP WHEN- TRIBAL PEOPLE SUCH AS-
THE ALONI- BECAUSE THE KNOWN AS
LONG PEOPLE ARE MAKING. A
REQUEST AT LEAST THERE'S A
RETURN PHONE CALL SOME DIALOGUE
MOVING FORWARD SO HOPEFULLY
THOSE ARE HEARING AND WILL
START TO IMPLEMENT SOME POLICY
THAT WOULD START TO ADDRESS
THOSE ISSUES WE HAVE ANY OTHER-
COMMENTS QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JUST A
COMMENTS AND YOU KNOW CHAIR
WOMAN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY BUT I WOULD JUST ADD
THAT- YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE SURE
YOU CONTACT OUR OFFICES WE CAN.
WE CAN CHECK WITH UC BERKELEY
ON THE COMMITTEE AND WHETHER OR
NOT THERE IS- WHETHER THE ALONI
GIVEN THE GEOGRAPHIC AREA SO
CLOSE TO UC BERKELEY- WHETHER
THERE'S REPRESENTATION ON THE
COMMITTEE AND SO. I WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU TO FOLLOW UP WITH
OUR OFFICES SO THAT WE CAN- AND
TURN FOLLOW UP WITH YOU SEASON
WITH UC BERKELEY'S COMMITTEE AS
WELL. ASSEMBLY WOMAN CARILLO.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN I THINK
WHAT WE'VE HEARD IS REALLY A
DESIRE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
AMERICAN INDIAN PEOPLE NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA IS ALIVE AND WELL
AND THRIVING AND THAT OUR
ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS THAT HAVE
A FOR MANY YEARS NOW BEEN
STEWART'S OF HOLDING ON TO-
BOTH KNOWLEDGE AS WELL AS
ARTIFACTS THAT CLEARLY BELONGED
TO SOVEREIGN PEOPLE- THERE IS
THAT THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR RESTITUTION. AND FOR THOSE
ITEMS TO BE DELIVERED BACK TO
THE COMMUNITY THAT THEY BELONG
TO IT IS A LARGER CONVERSATION
FOR NATIVE AND INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE NOT ONLY IN CALIFORNIA
BUT REALLY ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AND AROUND THE WORLD IN WHICH
WE SEE. THAT COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN CLEARLY COLONIZED IN
MANY WAYS HAVE HAD THEIR
HISTORY REMOVED THEIR LANGUAGE
REMOVED THEIR CULTURAL REMOVED.
AND ARE NOW IN MUSEUMS. WELL
COMMUNITIES ARE STILL VERY MUCH
ALIVE AND THRIVING. AND SO I
THINK WHAT WHAT IS
UNPRECEDENTED IN OUR
CONVERSATIONS HERE TODAY IS
REALLY HOW WE RE CONCILIATOR
HOW WE MOVE FORWARD. AND HOW WE
INSURE THAT ARE INDIGENOUS AND
NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITIES AT
LEAST IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ARSENE ACKNOWLEDGED
FOR THE COMMUNITIES THAT THEY
ARE TODAY. AND THAT THESE
UNPRECEDENTED HEARINGS WHICH
HAVE NEVER OCCURRED BEFORE IN
OUR STATE LEGISLATURE IN IN THE
PEOPLE'S HOUSE. ARE SEEN AS AS
IMPORTANT AS VALID AS A NEW
DONE FOR WHAT CALIFORNIA CAN BE
AND SHOULD BE. AND HOW WE
RECOVER FROM OUR PAST AND I'M
I'M SO GRATEFUL TO BE A PART OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND TO HEAR THE
POWERFUL TESTIMONIES TODAY. TO
ENSURE THAT THE VOICES OF
COMMUNITY ARE NOT ONLY PRESENT
BUT HEARD. AND THAT OUR
ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS DO THE
RIGHT THING AND FOLLOW SUIT
WELL WE ALL CONTINUE TO LEARN
FROM. OBVIOUSLY HISTORY IN OUR
PAST BUT THE WE CREATE A NEW
AND BOLD FUTURE AND I THINK
THAT'S THAT'S WHERE WE
CURRENTLY ARE AND I'M I'M SO
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP.
IN ENSURING THAT THESE
CONVERSATIONS ARE RECORDED. IN
OUR LEGISLATURE WHICH IS
IMPORTANT THEY HAVE NEVER BEEN
RECORDED BEFORE THESE
CONVERSATIONS HAVE NOT HAPPENED
IN THIS BUILDING. AND I THINK
THAT IS THE SHIFT. THAT WERE
SEEN THAT IS THE IMPORTANCE OF
THESE HEARINGS AND WHY THE
TESTIMONIES TODAY ARE CRITICAL.
AN AWFUL THE RESPONSIBILITY
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
OF UC BERKELEY AND OTHERS. TO
ENSURE THAT. WHATEVER THEY HAVE
WHATEVER IS BEING PETITIONED TO
BE GIVEN BACK TO ITS RIGHTFUL
OWNERS. IS RETURNED SO AGAIN I
COMMEND YOU AND I COMMEND ALL
OF OUR- OUR WITNESSES AND
TESTIMONIES TODAY TO ENSURE
THAT. AT THE END OF THE DAY
THERE'S ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY TO WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE THANK YOU THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYWOMAN COMMITTEE ON AND
THANK YOU- TO BOTH- CHAIRMAN
CISCO TOUCHY OKAY CHIME. IN THE
CHAIRWOMAN. LOUISE MARANDA
ROMERO'S OF THE LOANEE COSTA
KNOWN AS SALAH NATION THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AT THIS TIME
WILL MOVE TO- PUBLIC COMMENT IS
THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE
CHAMBERS. ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THE PHONE LINES. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF SO PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD ONCE AGAIN
IT'S ONE ZERO. AND WE CAN GO TO
THE LINE OF NUMBER ELEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I WOULD TREAT I'M
CALLING IN HEY IF SOMEONE
REPRESENTATIVES. TWENTY YEARS I
WANT TO THANK CAN SHARE BOTH
YOUR REMOTE. I MEAN IT'S
HEARING MAKE IT CORRECTION IS
BOTH THE ASSEMBLY THE DID THIS
FOR TIME IN BEEN HEARD TWENTY
EIGHT YEARS WE LEGISLATURE
ABOUT HOW BAD REPATRIATION WITH
TWENTY YEARS AGO TALKED
LEGISLATURE. WELL WE TALKED
LEGISLATURE AND TEN YEARS AGO
WE THE LEGISLATURE ARE YOU SEE
IS AN EXAMPLE THE EXAMPLE YOU
COULD NOT GET YOU SEE LA JOBS
GAVE THAT THAT AND THE KALALAU
NIGHT BEARING DIDN'T HARD. WORK
JOB IS NOT DONE BETTER. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS ON THE STREET ANY
OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT. AND
FURTHER FROM THE PHONE LINES.
ONE MORE TIME IN THE CHAMBERS.
MANY OTHERS ON THE PHONE LINES.
AGAIN ONE AND THEN ZERO IF SO.
AND CURRENTLY NO COMMENTS FROM
THE PHONE LINE. THE ALL RIGHT
WITH THANK YOU- IN CLOSING
REMARKS- WE'VE SEEN AND HEARD-
FRUSTRATION FROM THE TRIBAL
TESTIMONY AND PUBLIC COMMENT
AND THE FRUSTRATION OF
LEGISLATURES- THAT SEE THAT THE
RETURN OF REMAINS IS STILL
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH- HERE AND TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WE DO HAVE AN AUDIT REPORT
WHICH IS HEARING IS MEANT TO-
GIVE AN UPDATE OF WHERE THAT
PROCESS IS. WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE IS WORKABILITY- BUT WE
ALSO UNDERSTAND THERE CONTINUES
TO BE- FRUSTRATION AND GAPS
WE'RE HEARING THAT THE LOCAL
TRIBES ARE CALLING IN MAY OF
THIS YEAR AND HAVE NOT RETURNED
A CALL HAVE GOTTEN A RETURN
PHONE CALL THERE STILL IS A
PROBLEM THERE- WHEN WE HEAR
THAT. THE COMMITTEES AT THE UC
LEVEL- ARE WORKING STILL TO
IMPLEMENT- THAT EQUAL BALANCE
OF NATIVE AMERICAN- INDIVIDUALS
AS WELL AS- NON NATIVE AMERICAN
INDIVIDUALS WHICH- HAS BEEN
OVER BURDEN- BY ON THOSE
COMMITTEES BY NON. NATIVE
AMERICAN VOICES. WE HAVE TO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE DOING A
WANT TO LOSE SIGHT. OF SOME OF
THE GOOD WORK THAT HAS GONE ON
SOME OF THE PROCESS HAS MOVED
FORWARD. NATIVE AMERICAN
HERITAGE COMMISSION IS
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE UC
SYSTEM- COMPILED A LIST OF
MAKING SURE NOMINATIONS IN
THOSE LISTS ARE MOVING FORWARD
WHICH THIS BODY DOES NOT HAVE
OVERSIGHT ON THAT'S AN
INDIVIDUAL- PROCESS FOR THE
NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE
COMMISSION. BUT WE ALSO- HER AS
FAR AS REMAINS ENTERED ARE
MISSING. AND WE ARE REQUESTING
A FURTHER DATA- ON THOSE
MISSING- REMAINS THAT ARE OUT
THERE SO THAT WE COULD- START
TO LOOK AT HOW WE CAN BRING
CLOSURE TO IDENTIFY WHERE THOSE
REMAINS ARE AND SEARCHING FOR
THOSE BECAUSE THEY DO
REPRESENT- ANCESTORS FROM THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER WITH
CHAIRMAN SOLACE IN THAT AND J.
LACK- AND THE SELECT COMMITTEE
AMERICAN AFFAIRS. TO CONTINUE
TO HAVE A SERIES OF HEARINGS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
COMPLIANT. WE'VE HEARD ISSUES.
GOING BACK WITH BERKELEY AS FAR
AS ISHI AND SOME OF THOSE
THINGS AND IT'S NOT NEW
REPATRIATION IS NOTHING NEW- TO
THE UC SYSTEM. OR TO- THE
INDIAN PEOPLE. WHAT IS CHANGING
THOUGH IS PIECES OF LEGISLATION
THEY GIVE GIVE GREATER WEIGHT
TO ORAL TRADITIONS SO THAT THAT
CAN BE A PROCESS. TO MAKE SURE
THOSE REMAINS GET BACK TO THE
RIGHTFUL OWNERS. I WANT TO
THANK THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
MEMBERS OF THE BEEN HEARING
THAT VOICE CHEN. AND WE
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT AND
CONTINUE TO STAND TOGETHER TO
LIFT UP THE VOICES OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO PEOPLE. THIS
HEARING IS ADJOURNED.